Das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir schauen uns auf den Fußballfest.
Et voilà, César.
Mit diesem längsten Intro der Rasenfunk-Geschichte begrüße ich euch, liebe Hörer, zu einem Tribünengespräch. Und ihr habt vielleicht schon mitbekommen, wir haben einen weiten Bogen gespannt, allein schon in diesem Intro. Es hat angefangen beim UEFA-Interims-Generalsekretär Teodore Theodoridis, der sich auf die Party gefreut hat. Und dann kamen wir über viele, viele Fangesänge, einige sehr bekannte, einige vielleicht etwas unbekanntere, bis hin zu einem weiteren besonderen Moment der EM, aus meiner Sicht, dem Radiomoderator Joao Ricardo Patero, ein portugiesischer Radiosender, der den Soundcheck vor einer der Pressekonferenzen, vor dem Finale dazu genutzt hat, zu spoilern. Er hat einfach verraten, wer Europameister wird. Und niemand hat sich darüber aufgeregt. Wer hätte das gedacht? Also ihr merkt, liebe Hörer, es soll in diesem Tribüngespräch im Rasenfunk ein letztes Mal um die EM 2016 gehen. Und während wir in der Schlusskonferenz und in den vielen Kurzpässen die Spiele und die Mannschaften genauer beleuchtet haben, ist ein Thema noch ein bisschen zu kurz gekommen, nämlich, wie war es denn jetzt eigentlich vor Ort? Mein Name ist Max Hakob-Osti, ich bin der Ed Genetze und ich habe mir zwei Gäste zu diesem Thema eingeladen, die eben vor Ort waren und zwar die kompletten vier Wochen und die uns jetzt hoffentlich viele interessante Eindrücke schildern können. Zum einen mit seiner Rasenfunk-Premiere. Ich freue mich sehr, dass er mit dabei ist. Matthias Friebe vom Deutschlandfunk. Servus, Matthias. Und außerdem, ihr kennt ihn vielleicht schon aus früheren Senderungen, Tobias von meinsportradio.de. Servus, Tobias. Da sind schon nochmal ein paar Erinnerungen hochgekommen, oder, bei dem Intro? Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir ging, Matthias. Mir hat allein das Schneiden schon sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Ja, da sind eine Menge Erinnerungen hochgekommen und tatsächlich Ricardo Patero, der portugiesische Kollege, der da diesen Soundcheck der Pressekonferenz für so eine kleine eigene Show genutzt hat, der ist eine meiner Erinnerungen auf diese Europameisterschaft, weil ich zufällig genau bei dieser portugiesischen Pressekonferenz dabei war. Und es eine unglaubliche Stimmung war, das war der Freitag, also der Morgen nach dem Halbfinale Deutschland gegen Frankreich. Und ich bin mit einem Kollegen dahin gefahren, das ist das nationale Rugbyzentrum der Franzosen, ungefähr 35 Kilometer südlich von Paris. Und wir sind dahin gefahren und haben gedacht, okay, jetzt gucken wir mal die Portugiesen, was die so von Frankreich halten und ob die vielleicht sich eher Deutschland gewünscht hätten und mit welchen Erwartungen man halt so hinfährt, zu so einer Pressekonferenz und das war morgens um 10 und ungefähr zehn Minuten, bevor dann Joao Mario, der war der Spieler der Pressekonferenz, da auf dem Podium erschienen ist, hat der Kollege Patero da einen kleinen Soundcheck hingelegt und sich da derart in Stimmung gesungen und selbst von sich begeistert gewesen. War eine reine Freude und da hat man wirklich was gesehen, was man selten sieht. Da haben nämlich eigentlich geschlossen alle Journalisten ihr Handy gezogen, um ihr eigenes persönliches Erinnerungsfilmchen zu machen, weil alle total begeistert waren und als wir nachher weggegangen sind, da aus dem Zentrum, standen die Fernsehteams Schlange bei ihm. Er musste noch zahlreiche Interviews geben an einem Tag.
Ja siehst du mal, da habe ich ja schon, habe ich ja schon einen richtigen Griff getan bei der Auswahl der O-Töne. Wirklich ein besonderer Moment. Mich hat es ein bisschen erstaunt, dass mir das ehrlich gesagt nur so mal in einem Tweet von der Sportschau und dann habe ich es bei dir auch noch mal gesehen, über den Weg gelaufen ist und das gar nicht so sehr gefeiert wurde, aber Deutschland musste halt auch Wunden lecken.
Ja, ich glaube, das lag an dem Tag so, dass das damit zusammenhing. In anderen Ländern ist das deutlich mehr gefeiert worden. Also, die standen Schlange, die Kollegen, tatsächlich, um seinen Namen zu erfahren, um ihm Fragen zu stellen, was er da gesungen hat, dass er das noch mal übersetzt, auch ins Englische, dass wir alle verstehen – des Portugiesischen sind wir ja alle nicht so mächtig gewesen – was er da genau gesungen hat und das war so – ich kann das so ungefähr wiedergeben – also, wir spielen, wir treffen, wir gewinnen und am Ende gehen wir dann spazieren auf den Champs-Élysées mit dem Pokal in der Hand. Und so war es ja dann auch irgendwie.
Ja, ich habe es gesagt, ein ganz fieser Spoiler eigentlich, aber wie das so ist, weiß man natürlich dann erst im Nachhinein. Wir haben es jetzt schon so ein bisschen erahnen können, Matthias, du warst für den Deutschlandfunk als Journalist vier Wochen vor Ort bei dem Turnier. Das heißt, wie viele Spiele hast du gesehen? Was war dann so deine Rolle vor Ort?
Also meine Rolle war gar nicht die, die man jetzt erwarten könnte im Stadion als Live-Kommentator der Spiele. Das sind ja die ganzen ARD-Kollegen. Es ist ja ein großes ARD-Team unterwegs gewesen mit den bekannten Namen, die wir glaube ich alle kennen, ob sie nun André Siems heißen oder Philipp Hofmeister, Armin Lehmann. Das sind ja die Namen, die wir aus der Bundesligakonferenz kennen. Die waren auch vor Ort in den Stadien und meine Aufgabe war so ein bisschen on top sozusagen, die Geschichten drum rum zu machen, die die Geschichten, die jetzt so nicht direkt absolut das Top-Thema des Tages waren. Also ich habe zum Beispiel ein Spiel in der Philharmonie geguckt, weil da die Pariser Philharmonie live improvisiert hat, den Kommentar in Musik. Oder ich war – ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitbekommen habt – bestimmt der Eiffelturm wurde jeden Abend angestrahlt in den Landesfarben. Da habe ich da mal so eine Hintergrundgeschichte dazu gemacht, wie das kommt und wie das geht und warum man das macht. Also das waren so im Prinzip die Geschichten und dann habe ich natürlich aber auch, weil ich ja auch was von der EM mitbekommen wollte, weil ich auch den ein oder anderen Analyse-Einsatz hatte, um so Spiele mal in der Halbzeitpause zu analysieren, habe ich ja auch einige Spiele geguckt und war dann im Endeffekt bei sieben Spielen vor Ort, die meisten in der Vorrunde und dann noch zwei Achtelfinale und ein Viertelfinale unter anderem. Das war dann mein Glück in Bordeaux, Deutschland, Italien. Das einzige Spiel der deutschen Mannschaft, was ich gesehen habe bei dem Turnier.
Nicht schlecht. Okay, wir spielen jetzt ein virtuelles Stich. Du hast sieben EM-Spiele live gesehen. Tobi, kannst du das toppen?
Ja, sieben in der Hauptrunde und vier in der Vorrunde waren es bei mir tatsächlich. Fünfmal Deutschland, wenn mich jetzt so nicht ganz alles täuscht. Ja genau, fünfmal Deutschland, es wären sechs gewesen, wenn sie das Finale erreicht hätten. Das war mein Mix in der Zeit.
Wahnsinn. Tobi, alle Hörer beneiden dich und fragen sich, wie hat der Mann das geschafft?
Planung, frühe Planung, also ich habe tatsächlich, ich glaube es war Mai 2015, also so gut 13 Monate vor dem Turnier habe ich angefangen mir Gedanken zu machen, möchtest du dahin? Wenn ja, wie möchtest du dahin? Und mit wem? Das ist ja dann immer, wie das so ist, wenn man dann sich so seine Gedanken macht, dann ruft man Leute an und schreibt Nachrichten und plant und überlegt und guckt sich den Turnierverlauf an und damals war ja noch – ich glaube damals war Deutschland noch nicht mal qualifiziert, aber ich wollte dann schon so ein bisschen Deutschland auch sehen, aber nicht nur, sondern auch ein bisschen rumkommen, ein bisschen was von dagegen sehen, also es musste irgendwie so eine Mischung her und dann musste natürlich irgendwo ran das Thema mit den Tickets geklärt werden, das ist ja das größte Problem bei so einem Turnier, denkt man zumindest am Anfang erstmal, also Spoiler-Alarm, so schwierig ist das alles gar nicht. Aber damals habe ich gedacht, es geht alles, also man muss es nur wollen und man muss noch nicht mal sich in irgendwelche dunklen Ecken vorm Stadion begeben, man kann es auch tatsächlich alles ganz regulär über die UEFA klären, wenn man sich frühzeitig Gedanken macht. Und das habe ich gemacht und ich habe, wie gesagt, im Mai, Juni, das ist dann immer so eine Geschichte, die großen Internetseiten dieser Welt, wo man Hotels buchen kann, die gehen meistens so 12 Monate in die Zukunft, kann man buchen, also dementsprechend war dann, ich glaube, der erste Sechste, weil dann wurde der Juni 2016 und dann der erste Siebte, da wurde der Juli 2016 freigeschaltet. Das waren dann so die wichtigen Termine, wo man dann nachts sich auf den Internetseiten herumgetrieben hat und Hotels reserviert hat, wie ein Bekloppter, wenn man ja nicht wusste, wo kriege ich Karten, wo könnte ich hinfahren, wo geht so ein Turnierverlauf von Deutschland vielleicht lang. Und dann habe ich tatsächlich damals für alle – wie viele sind es? 8 plus 4 plus 2 plus 1, das müssen dann 15 sein – für alle 15 K.O.-Spiele ein Hotel reserviert. Immer in der Stadt, also es ging, es war gar nicht so ganz schwierig, ich habe das verteilt auf zwei, drei Seiten, damit das nicht so aussieht, dass ich quasi an einem Tag in vier Orten bin. Man hat ja immer so ein bisschen Sorge, dass die dann vielleicht auch aufs Turnieren kommen oder so, aber alles kein Problem gewesen, hatte genug Hotels reserviert und hatte dann erstmal so ein bisschen Ruhe, was die Zukunft angeht, weil ich wusste, egal wo es hingeht, ich habe überall ein Hotel und ich habe überall ein Hotel, was so einigermaßen im Bereich von bezahlbar ist. Man kann natürlich auch drei Wochen vor dem Turnier buchen, das ist überhaupt kein Problem, aber dann kriegst du halt, naja, in manchen Städten gar nichts und in vielen Städten, ich sag mal so ein 0815-Doppelzimmer für 300, 400 Euro aufwärts und wie bei fast jedem Fußballfan sind natürlich die finanziellen Grenzen da und man kann nicht unendlich Geld ausgeben. Deshalb dachte ich mir einfach clever sein, früh buchen und das hat auch geklappt. Also wie gesagt, für die K.o.-Runde hatte ich dann für jedes Spiel ein Hotelzimmer, immer ein Doppelzimmer in den jeweiligen Städten gebucht. Manchmal brauchte man auch nur eins, weil im Achtelfinale zum Beispiel L'Anse und Lille, wie wir jetzt ja inzwischen wissen, in L'Anse ist jetzt nicht so viel los, also man schläft tatsächlich in Lille, wenn man in L'Anse ein Fußballspiel gucken will. Das waren zwei Spiele, die dann an aufeinander folgenden Tagen lagen. Da hat man dann halt einmal drei Nächte in Lille gebucht und hatte damit L'Anse und Lille abgedeckt. Gleiches galt, glaube ich, noch für Saint-Etienne und Lyon. Also es waren dann am Ende irgendwie 1312 Hotels für die K.O.-Phase und was die Vorrunde anging, da haben wir gesagt, da gucken wir erstmal, vielleicht machen wir da irgendwas mit Wohnwagen und Camping oder so. Da haben wir jetzt nichts gebucht. Zumal es halt auch einfach Wahnsinn ist, für alle Vorrundenspiele sich was zu buchen. Deshalb haben wir da tatsächlich erstmal nichts gemacht.
Also wir halten fest, du bist ein sehr, sehr vorausschauender Mensch und hast im Mai und Juni 2015, indem wir nur daran gedacht haben, dass jetzt mal Sommerpause ist und der Fußball pausiert, da hast du ganz weit vorausgedacht und gebucht und gleichzeitig bist du der Typ, den man bei Monopoly immer hat. Du hattest überall ein Hotel.
Ja, ich hätte es aber jetzt nicht mit hohen Gebühren verbunden. Also tatsächlich durfte jeder, der mich begleitet hat auf der Reise, zum Standardpreis in meinem Hotel schlafen und hat keine Zuschläge gezahlt. Also das Mittelhotel war wirklich überraschend einfach und man hört immer viele Horrorgeschichten, wenn man in diesem Internet ein bisschen rumblättert. Das soll man ja sowieso nicht machen. Von Stornierung kurz vor Ende, weil die Hoteliers dann halt auch merken, ach Mensch, da haben wir dem Jungen das Doppelzimmer für 100 verkauft, da könnten wir doch heute 300 für nehmen. Stornieren, stornieren wir mal aus irgendwelchen fadenscheinigen Gründen. Das ist mir allerdings nicht passiert.
Ja, also ihr habt es mitbekommen, liebe Hörer, wir haben quasi einmal die Fansicht und dann haben wir noch den, gut gearbeitet hast du ja auch Tobi, ich täte dir jetzt unrecht, wenn ich sagen würde.
Ach naja, komm, das bisschen.
Also man konnte auf meinsportradio.de deine Reise mitverfolgen und auch viele interessante Geschichten erfahren, unter anderem zur Ticketbuchung, dazu kommen wir noch, wie das alles so lief. Matthias, wie lief denn bei dir so die Vorbereitung auf das Turnier? Ich vermute mal, du hast nicht schon zwölf Monate vorher angefangen.
Nein, ganz und gar nicht. Zwölf Monate vorher habe ich nicht mal im Traum dran gedacht, nach Paris zu fahren und die Europameisterschaft zu begleiten. Damit habe ich mich erst Anfang des Jahres beschäftigt, als das so langsam auf mich zukam. Und ich glaube, ich kann es gar nicht mehr genau sagen, das war Februar oder März, als klar war, ich würde hinfahren und mitmachen, dann als Journalist für den Deutschlandfunk. Und dann beschäftigt man sich erst mal mit anderen Fragen. Dann geht es um Akkreditierungsfragen, das ist auch gar nicht so einfach. Dann geht es um viele andere Dinge. Meine Hotels habe ich tatsächlich nicht so weit im Voraus gebucht. Der Extremfall war Viertelfinale Deutschland-Italien. Ich glaube, das war zwei Tage vorher oder so, weil ich tatsächlich auch nicht über Pressekarten, irgendwie über Akkreditierungsfreikarten im Stadion war, sondern mich auf der offiziellen UEFA-Seite, auf dem Last-Minute-Markt immer wie ein normaler Fan bewegt habe und Tickets gekauft habe. Und das Achtelfinale der Deutschen gegen die Slowakei war ja glaube ich ein Sonntag und dann gab es am Montag oder am Dienstag, ich glaube, Dienstag war es, gab es die Last-Minute-Tickets und da habe ich eins bekommen und habe dann irgendwie Mittwochs oder Donnerstags mein Hotel gebucht. Und ja, so das war alles eher kurzfristig, weil ich mich auch relativ viel im Land bewegt habe. Ich war zwar in Paris stationiert, aber ich habe auch in Lyon-Spiel geguckt und in Saint-Tien und in Lille. Und zwischendurch war ich nochmal für zwei Tage in der Normandie, um bei der Tour de France so ein bisschen zuzugucken. Und deswegen war das alles gar nicht so weit im Voraus planbar, sondern eher spontan und war dann so ein bisschen mit auch mit Aufwand während des Turniers verbunden.
Muss man auch erstmal die Redaktion haben, die einem da so freie Leinen lässt, oder?
Absolut, die Gelegenheit da an dieser Stelle auch Dankeschön zu sagen.
Hast du noch in den ersten zehn Minuten platzieren können, wo sie wahrscheinlich noch zugehen. Die EM war ja für die UEFA, wenn man mal auf das Finanzielle guckt, ein Riesenerfolg. 830 Millionen Euro Gewinn, das ist neue Rekordmarke, hängt wesentlich damit zusammen, dass es mehr Spiele waren und damit auch die TV-Richte gestiegen sind. 600 Millionen davon sollen übrigens an die 55 Verbände fließen, also alle Verbände, die in der UEFA organisiert sind. Die UEFA hat sich auch kurz vorm Finale nochmal wirklich mit allen verfügbaren Händen auf alle verfügbaren Schultern geklopft. Alles wäre eigentlich super gewesen und auch Fanprobleme immer nur der Alkoholschuld, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Dazu kommen wir noch. Jetzt würde mich aber mal interessieren, gerade aus Sicht des Fans. Tobi, du hast ja dann schon für die Hotels musstest du ganz schön in Vorleistung gehen, ich denke auch finanziell. Wie war es denn dann bei den Tickets und wie lief das eigentlich ab? Wie bist du dann an deine Tickets gekommen?
Hotels keine Vorleistung. Wer clever bucht, bucht natürlich mit Bezahlung erst vor Ort und stornierbar bis einen Tag vorher. Und das habe ich dann tatsächlich auch gemacht. Manchmal sind sie deshalb ein bisschen teurer, die Hotels, aber grundsätzlich kein Problem. Da muss man nicht einen Cent vorstrecken. Das sind dann halt nur ein paar Stunden, die man sich nachts um die Ohren steckt. Ich habe bei Tickets tatsächlich – da musst du in Vorleistung gehen, das ist richtig – es gab ja mehrere Verkaufsphasen. Die UEFA dramatisiert das ein wenig über, finde ich. Sie haben, glaube ich, am Anfang gesagt, es gibt drei Verkaufsphasen. Einmal die erste, das war noch letztes Jahr, bevor überhaupt fest stand, wer spielt, wer überhaupt beim Turnier dabei ist. Da hat man quasi blind seine Karten gekauft. Das war auch so die größte Verkaufsphase. Da gab es halt auch die meisten Tickets zu kaufen. Man hat also ins Blaue hinein eingekauft. Das habe ich natürlich auch gemacht, weil ich dachte mir, ich will da ja hin und da kann man erst mal sich auf Tickets bewerben. Und ich muss gestehen, dass ich das ein bisschen unterschätzt habe. Also zumindest unterschätzt habe, wie viele Karten man so bekommen kann. Das lief folgendermaßen ab. Man könnte sich pro Tag, also pro Kalendertag, auf ein Spiel bewerben. Und das das ganze Turnier durch. Und das habe ich natürlich getan. Und ich habe immer, weil ich davon ausgegangen bin, dass Deutschland irgendwie als Gruppenkopf gesetzt sein wird. Also als A1 war ja Frankreich gesetzt. Und dann blieb eigentlich nur, dass die B1, C1, D1, E oder F1 werden. Und dementsprechend habe ich dann auch so meine Spiele ausgewählt, dass ich häufig halt den Gruppenkopf gegen irgendwen an dem Tag rausgepickt habe. Und beim Achtelfinals waren ja auch immer zwei oder drei Spieler am Tag. Da war es dann halt Lotterie, was man genommen hat. Da hat man dann ja meistens die größeren Stadien genommen oder das, was irgendwie einigermaßen sinnvoll liegt oder so. Das war so ein bisschen ins Blaue hinein, halt die ganze Geschichte. Und ja, das hat nicht nur ich gemacht, das hat mein Vater auch gemacht für mich. Also für sich, für mich. Na ja, ist auch egal. Er hat es auf jeden Fall auch gemacht. Und ja, dann irgendwann, ich weiß gar nicht, es muss irgendwie Richtung Oktober gegangen sein oder so, keine Ahnung, kamen dann die Mails von der UEFA, was einem zugeteilt wurde. Und ich bin da halt von meinen bisherigen Erfolgsschancen bei Champions League-Finals und ähnlichen Sachen ausgegangen. Da kriegste halt, weiß nicht, 5%, vielleicht 10% deiner Ticketwünsche. Ja, ich bin mich ein bisschen vertan, es waren eher so 20 bis 25%, und auf einmal hatte ich doch relativ viele Karten. Also ich habe tatsächlich in dieser ersten Verkaufsphase Karten für die beiden Halbfinals gekriegt, für das Viertelfinale in Marseille, für allerhand Vorrundenspiele. Und hatte dann Karten, von denen ich nicht wusste, wer da am Ende spielen wird. Das war relativ dubios, aber es ist so ein bisschen komisches System. UEFA macht es natürlich schlau, um solche Spiele, wie zum Beispiel Rumänien gegen Albanien, die natürlich nicht so die Verkaufsschlager sind, einfach frühzeitig unter das Volk zu kriegen, wenn man noch nicht weiß, wer da spielt. Hat mich jetzt im konkreten Fall nicht getroffen, aber ich kenne genug Leute, die Rumänien gegen Albanien-Karten hatten in Lyon.
Was ja auch ein großes Stadion ist, kann man an dieser Stelle ja auch mal sagen.
Was definitiv ein großes Stadion ist und ein sehr schönes Stadion übrigens auch, hat mir sehr, sehr gut gefallen.
Mit einem kleinen Baufehler, kurzer Exkurs, mit einem kleinen Baufehler, wenn es regnet, kann der Unterrang in die Katakomben laufen, weil nämlich alle nass werden.
Das hat aber noch ein anderes Stadion, das haben einige. Na ja, ist auch egal. In Frankreich regnet es einfach nicht so fertig. Zumindest im Dünen nicht.
In Lyon hat das Spiel stattgefunden, wo es unterbrochen werden musste wegen Hagel.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Gott sei Dank war ich erst später da. Zu den Tickets zurückzukommen. Ich hatte dann relativ viele und spannend war dann, anfangs Dezember, die Auslosung, als es dann hieß, wer spielt eigentlich wo. Und dann wurden aus C1 gegen C3, wurde dann Deutschland gegen, ich glaube Ukraine und so. Also es bildeten sich tatsächlich Spiele dann heraus und man konnte sehen, was man hat und was man davon vielleicht wirklich braucht und was man eher nicht braucht. Es gibt in diesem Internet Gott sei Dank tolle Foren, wo Menschen Karten tauschen wie verrückt, weil sie einfach Spiele sehen wollen, wo sie keine Karten für haben. Offizielle Foren oder? Das ist kein offizielles UEFA Forum natürlich, aber das, was mich daran sehr positiv begeistert hat und gereizt hat, war die Tatsache, da wird nicht zum höheren Preis verkauft. Also es wird nicht geboten oder ähnliches, sondern es ist einfach der Face Value, also das, was auf der Karte drauf steht. Für den Preis kannst du es kaufen oder verkaufen oder du lässt es halt oder du tauschst es eins zu eins. Also kein Schwarzmarkt in dem Sinne von, ich habe hier ein super Spiel, was weiß ich, Deutschland gegen Polen oder so und möchte gerne 100 statt 50 Euro haben oder solche Geschichten. Nein, es wird eins zu eins getauscht und das, was auf der Karte drauf steht, ist das, was bezahlt wird, maximal plus ein Bier und eine Bratwurst. Damit werben sie quasi. Und das wird auch tatsächlich eingehalten, wenn sich da Leute daneben benehmen, werden sie direkt gesperrt, fliegen raus. Und da sind echte Menschen, die ich tatsächlich auch vor Ort getroffen habe, zum Karten tauschen, zum Bierchen trinken und solche Geschichten. Also wirklich eine feine Sache. Und da habe ich viel getauscht. Also da habe ich dann aus zum Beispiel, jetzt muss ich kurz überlegen, was ich damals denn hatte. Ich hatte Spanien gegen Kroatien in Bordeaux am 21.06. Brauchte ich nicht, passte überhaupt nicht in meinen Plan. Habe ich getauscht, glaube ich, gegen Deutschlandspiel oder so. Also gute Menschen, zuverlässige Menschen, mit denen man da wirklich dann seinen Kartenkontingent so legen kann, dass es passt, dass man das hat, was man quasi haben möchte. Und gerade aus dieser ersten Verkaufsphase, wo man ins Blaue hineingekauft hat, dann endlich vernünftige Karten kriegen konnte, die man auch wirklich braucht für seine Tour.
Tobi, weil du das bestimmt noch ganz genau vor Augen hast, aber ich jetzt zum Beispiel nicht und bestimmt auch manche höre nicht, was waren denn eigentlich denn so die Kategorien und über welche Preise reden wir für die Karten?
Habe ich tatsächlich vor Augen, ja. Preise sind, naja, also es ist, man muss es von mehreren Seiten betrachten. Ich finde, die Preise für die Vorrundenspiele und für die Achtelfinalspiele, das war das, was quasi ein Preis war, finde ich persönlich ist völlig in Ordnung. Es gibt vier Kategorien. Vier ist die günstigste, eins ist die teuerste. Wir reden davon Kategorie 4 von 25 Euro für eine Karte. Da sind nicht viele Tickets im Stadion, sind wir uns auch einig, das ist hinter dem Tor entweder ganz unten oder ganz oben. Keine Ahnung, je nachdem, wie groß das Stadion ist, sind es vielleicht 1000 Plätze im Stadion, vielleicht auch 2000. Ich weiß es nicht, kommt wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen drauf an. Es gibt Gerüchte, dass zum Beispiel das vorhin angesprochene Spiel Albanien gegen Rumänien, dass da dann auch mal Kategorie 2 Plätze zur Kategorie 4 umfunktioniert wurde in der Verkaufsphase 9, 10 und 11 oder so. Damit man sie dann losführt.
Es gab 11 Verkaufsphasen, du warst doch erst bei 1.
Ich würde behaupten, es gab 25. Matthias hat es ja vorhin angesprochen, es gab ja noch den allerlast minute Einkauf und solche Geschichten. Es gab unfassbar viele Verkaufsphasen, wo 3 oder 4 am Anfang angekündigt waren. Und dann gab es immer mal wieder noch mal Karten und noch mal Karten. Das war sehr, sehr abenteuerlich.
Besonders für Rumänien und Albanien übrigens. Die sind noch am Spieltag selbst auf dem last minute Markt erschienen.
Dabei war es ein historisches Spiel. Nachdem wir jetzt so oft indirekt über Rumänien gegen Albanien gelästert haben, will ich mal kurz einwerfen, das war der erste Sieg Albaniens. Und direkt nach Schlusspfiff gab es noch Chancen aufs Achtelfinale. Also das Spiel war ja dann gar nicht so schlimm.
Aber natürlich nicht der Verkaufsschlager.
Und gleichzeitig spielte eben Frankreich.
Genau, und gleichzeitig spielte die Schweiz gegen die Frankreich.
0 zu 0 gegen die Schweiz.
Fürchterliches Fußballspiel. Ja, also es gab viele Verkaufsphasen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es 25 waren, vielleicht waren es auch 35 oder nur 15, aber es waren sehr, sehr viele. Und das lag halt auch an den Preisen für Kategorie 1. Und wenn ich jetzt gesagt habe, dass Kategorie 4 vielleicht 1000, vielleicht 2000 Plätze im Stadion waren, war Kategorie 3, die in der Vorrunde sich bei 55 Euro bewegten. Der große Teil hinter dem Tor, das war auch so die Hauptkategorie, wo ich meistens gelandet bin, weil es A, natürlich mehr Tickets gibt als in Kategorie 4 und B, ich finde, mit 55 Euro für ein Europameisterschaftsvorrundenspiel oder auch ein Achtelfinale, das ist noch bezahlbar. Die anderen Kategorien sind dann 105, 145. Da finde ich, weiß nicht, Deutschland, Ukraine, 145 Euro. Und dann hast du oft die Enttäuschung, dass Kategorie 1 gar nicht mittellinie ist, weil mittellinie ist dann natürlich das Gold-VIP-Paket oder solche Geschichten oder das Platin-VIP-Paket. Das heißt, du zahlst 145 Euro und sitzt dann doch nur Höhe 16er. Dann zahle ich lieber 55 und sitze hinterm Tor und habe eigentlich doch eine ganz gute Sicht von hinten auf dieses Spiel. Das sind so ungefähr die Preise gewesen in der Vorrunde. Es gab dann nach oben quasi keine Grenzen. Beim Finale Kategorie 1 895 Euro. Das war die teuerste Karte des Turniers.
830 Millionen Euro Einnahmen. Es sind nicht nur die TV-Rechter. Irgendwo muss es herkommen. Und mein Gott, die UEFA braucht es ja auch wirklich. Weil du gerade gesagt hast, du saß hinter dem Tor, würde mich mal interessieren, bei wie vielen Spielen warst du denn tatsächlich gesessen und bei wie vielen warst du gestanden? Und dann darf Matthias gleich mit seiner Zahl kontern.
Tatsächlich gestanden durchgehend 90 Minuten bei einem einzigen Spiel von 11. Das war das Spiel Deutschland gegen Polen, weil ich dort wirklich Karten hatte für den Deutschlandblock über den Fanclub Nationalmannschaft. Da sind wir dann bei Verkaufsphase 2. Das war das, wo man über die nationalen Verbände die Karten kaufen konnte, wo dann auch diesen großen Ärger gab, dass man extra in die Fanclub Nationalmannschaft eintreten musste, 40 Euro bezahlen musste und so weiter und so fort. Diese ganzen Sachen, die da ausreichend durch die Presse gegangen sind. Das waren die einzigen Karten, die ich tatsächlich genutzt habe über den Fanclub Nationalmannschaft. Und da stand ich im Stade de France hinterm Tor mittig in der weiße nicht zehnten Reihe von unten. Und es standen halt alle Leute um mich herum. Dementsprechend musste ich auch stehen. Alle anderen Spiele habe ich tatsächlich über den freien Verkauf von UEFA bekommen oder getauscht. Und dementsprechend waren es relativ neutrale Blöcke. Also ich habe tatsächlich dreimal neben den Portugiesen gesessen, aber halt neben. Und so wie dieser Fanblock zu Ende ist, und man sieht das halt im Fernsehen ja auch relativ gut. Fanblock, Trikots, ganz klar die Farbe des Landes oder zumindest irgendwie der Flagge oder wie auch immer. Und daneben endet das und dann sitzen die Leute da. Und so habe ich tatsächlich bei vielen eigentlichen Sitzplatz gehabt, wo man, naja, wenn man aufsteht auch ein bisschen komisch angeguckt wird. Also spannende Szenen und so weiter, Jubel, alles kein Thema, konnte man aufstehen. Aber grundsätzlich waren das Sitzplatzkarten und das waren auch wirklich durchgesetzte Sitzplätze.
So Matthias, und warst du mal gestanden?
Ja, tatsächlich bei einem Spiel, da hat es mich in die Österreicher Kurve verschlagen. Österreich gegen Island im Stade de France, wo nachher ganz viele rot-weiß-rote Fans geweint haben. Da war ich tatsächlich in einem Block voller Österreich-Fans und habe im Prinzip das ganze Spiel über gestanden. Gegen Beispiel, Achtelfinale Sainte-Aitien, Schweiz gegen Polen. Da habe ich auf einem Platz gesessen, wo eine Ordnerin hinter mir gestanden hat, die mir quasi, wann immer ich aufstehen wollte, weil die Reihen vor mir gestanden haben, sofort die Hand auf die Schulter gelegt hat und gesagt, setz dich bloß wieder hin, weil ich nämlich tatsächlich genau in der Reihe saß, hinter der die Rollstuhlfahrer aufgestellt waren und ihren Platz hatten. Kann ich natürlich verstehen, die haben einfach überhaupt keine Chance gehabt, wenn ich da gestanden habe. Ich bin auch nicht der Kleinste, sage ich dazu, aber das wäre auch egal gewesen, wenn man da hätte 1, 50 Körpergröße gereicht, die hätten nichts mehr gesehen. Das ist etwas schlecht gelöst in einem Stadion, weil die einfach im Gang stehen, direkt hinter der letzten Reihe, ohne irgendwie ein Podest oder so. Und da war tatsächlich 120 Minuten konzentrierter Sitzen angesagt. Was dann zum Elfmeterschießen aufgelöst wurde, als die Rollstuhlfahrer sich auch, wie ich finde, völlig zu Recht gegen alle Regeln hinweggesetzt haben und sich selbst einen Platz gesucht haben in der Nähe des Tores, dass sie überhaupt eine Chance hatten, was zu sehen. Weil nach diesem Spiel, wer da zum Elfmeterschießen in die Röhre gucken muss oder sich die breiten oder nicht so breiten Rücken der Vorderleute angucken muss, ist ja absolute Katastrophe.
Ja, allerdings. Und da muss ich aber die Frage stellen, wenn du bei Island gegen Österreich warst, hat man den Kommentator denn auch auf deinen Platz gehört, den isländischen natürlich?
Nein, den hat man nicht gehört. Man hat stattdessen den österreichischen Stadionsprecher immer wieder gehört, der da versucht hat, richtig einzuhizen. Und das war ja offenbar, habe ich im Nachhinein auch noch gehört, für österreichische Verhältnisse ein fast schon Rekordspiel, was die Zahl der Fans anging und die Zahl der Begeisterung, was sich ja dann im Ergebnis nicht niedergeschlagen hat. Aber es war schon, wie ich fand, relativ beeindruckend, wie viel Rot-Weiß-Rote im Stadion war, die dann relativ schnell nach Hause ging und die blaue Kurve blieb dann über nach dem Spiel.
Und es schalte ein isländisches Hu in die EM-Narration.
Da habe ich es zum ersten Mal live mitbekommen. Ich habe es ja vorher auch nur am Fernseher gesehen und tatsächlich durchaus beeindruckend, muss ich sagen.
Ja, warten wir mal ab, wenn das dann auch die Fans des FC irgendwo stattmachen nach einem 1-2-1 gegen Hoffenheim. Ob das dann noch so beeindruckend ist?
Ich bin ziemlich sicher, dass wir das in der Bundesliga hören werden in der nächsten Saison.
Auf jeden Fall.
Wie schon einige andere auch. Will Brick ist on fire, wenn wir auch hören, bin ich ziemlich sicher. Und ich glaube, auch spätestens im Abstiegskampf hören wir Don't Take Me Home.
Ja, schauen wir mal. Ich meine, Hertha hat das ja schon mit. Nur nach Hause gehen wir nicht. Ist das nicht einfach nur ein Cover? Das führt jetzt vielleicht etwas weit. Tobi, du hast schon einen interessanten Punkt angesprochen, nämlich die Verkaufsphase 2, wie ich jetzt gelernt habe, in der man für deutsche Spiele nur Karten bekam, wenn man Mitglied im Fanclub-Nationalmannschaft vorher wurde, worüber es dann ja auch zu Recht, wie ich finde, Beschwerden gab. Das heißt, du bist jetzt ein stolzes Fanclub-Nationalmannschaftsmitglied und hat das noch andere Folgen, außer dass du den 40 Euro jetzt überweisen musstest für ein Jahr? Kriegt man von denen vielleicht noch ganz tolle Anfeuerungs-E-Mails? Wurde dir Shetem ins Hirn geprügelt?
Ganz kleinen Moment, ich muss kurz die Kündigung zu Ende schreiben. Ja, ich bin tatsächlich auch nur deswegen natürlich eingetreten, war vorher nicht Mitglied im FNK und denke mal 2017, bin ich dann aus dieser Geschichte auch schnell wieder raus. Also ja, ich habe natürlich auch den Kopf geschüttelt und gesagt, warum? Grundsätzlich kann ich den Ansatz dahinter verstehen, finde es dann aber sehr abenteuerlich, wenn Leute eintreten, keine Tickets kriegen und dann, ja, sich dann beschweren und dann sagen, ich habe keine Leute, aber dann will ich wenigstens meine 40 Euro wieder, wenn ich hier eingetreten bin und nichts davon hatte. Da gab es ja dann auch noch mal großen Ärger drum. Also ja, Fanclub Nationalmannschaft, da wird sicherlich viel drauf rumgehackt und da wird auch aus vielen Gründen ganz passend drauf rumgehackt. Ich kann verstehen, wenn der DFB sagt, okay, wir kriegen es nicht ohne eine Dachorganisation hin, irgendwie eine Choreo im Stadion zu organisieren oder sonst irgendwas. Die gab es ja tatsächlich bei jedem Deutschlandspiel, zumindest bei jedem, wo ich war, gab es zumindest in irgendeiner Form irgendeine Choreo, sei es irgendwelche Fähnchen oder ein Banner, was da hochgezogen wurde. Das war nicht immer ganz glücklich und sah auch nicht immer ganz gäulich aus, aber es wurde so ein bisschen was gemacht. Außerdem gibt es vor Ort die Fanbotschaft, das haben die Deutschen jetzt nicht alleine, das gab es, glaube ich, von jeder Nation, die vor Ort war. Immer an einem zentralen Punkt, meistens irgendwie in der Stadt oder in der Nähe von dieser Fanmeile, gibt es die Fanbotschaft, wo sich dann Leute hinwenden können, ihre Probleme oder Fragen zur Stadt oder wie auch immer äußern können. Tatsächlich kenne ich eine Geschichte von einem Bekannten, der dank der DFB-Leute vor Ort seine geklauten Tickets dann noch gesperrt gekriegt hat und neue ausgestellt gekriegt hat. Also das wollte die UEFA irgendwie nicht ganz so machen, wie er wollte. Dann hat sich die DFB-Fan-Abteilung da eingeschaltet und er konnte dann das, ich glaube, es war das Achtelfinale in Lille, konnte er noch sehen. Also es gibt tatsächlich gute Geschichten von Leuten, die davon profitieren und die davon was haben. Ich persönlich kann auch zu so einem Spiel gehen, ohne den Fan-Top-Nationalmannschaft besucht zu haben oder da drin zu sein. Das ist sicherlich auch bei fast jedem so, aber es schadet manchmal auch nicht, dass sie da sind. Also, ja, ich verstehe jeden, der sich so ein bisschen drüber lustig macht, über diese ganze Geschichte und kann auch sehr gut leben, wenn das Ding powered by Brause Coca-Cola oder wie das Ding heißt, wenn es das nicht mehr gibt. Aber es gibt sie halt und man musste sich nun da für 40 Euro – es gab übrigens einen großartigen Schal und ich glaube, was war denn da noch in dem Päckchen? Keine Ahnung. Habe ich beides nicht so wirklich ausgemacht. Ich glaube, einen Schlüsselanhänger oder so gab es als Startgeschenk für die 40 Euro noch dazu.
Na gut, das ist natürlich krass. Das wiegt so einiges auf. Aber schließe ich dann richtig, dass es in jener Verkaufsphase zwei dann schwieriger war, an Tickets zu kommen, wenn du von Leuten sprichst, die eben genau das nicht geschafft haben?
Ja, das weiß ich nicht. Also die Wege der Ticketverteilung sind unergründlich wirklich. Das ist ganz, ganz abenteuerlich. Es gibt Leute, die haben gar keine Karten gekriegt. Wie gesagt, ich hatte, glaube ich, eine Trefferquote von 20, 25 Prozent in der ersten Verkaufsphase. In der zweiten Verkaufsphase waren wir dann drei Kumpels, die alle eingetreten sind. Dann konnte man angeben, dass man mit denen zusammen gerne die Tickets haben möchte. Und wir haben tatsächlich für fünf von sieben Spielen Karten gekriegt. Also du kriegst ja für die Vorrunde tatsächlich Karten. Und ab dem Achtelfinale sind es Voucher, die du vor Ort am Stadion einlösen kannst, wenn dein Team, also in dem Fall Deutschland, das Spiel oder die Runde erreicht. Und da haben wir tatsächlich für die drei Vorrundenspiele und Halbfinale und Finale eine Zuteilung gekriegt. Also fünf von sieben ist auch eigentlich eine sehr gute Quote. Von daher kann ich jetzt eigentlich nicht behaupten, dass es in der Phase schwieriger war, an Karten zu kommen. Ich kenne aber tatsächlich genug Geschichten, wo Leute gar nichts gekriegt haben. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was die für eine Vorgeschichte haben. Weiß ich nicht, will ich mich nicht einmischen. Aber bei mir mit fünf von sieben auf jeden Fall reichlich bedacht worden mit Tickets. Teilweise auch mit Tickets in Kategorien, die ich gar nicht so gerne hatte. Also Kategorie zwei im Halbfinale, 295 Euro, stolze Summe.
Ja, oh ja, das kann man dann auch.
Und du musst sie halt nehmen. Du bezahlst sie vorab. Also du bezahlst sie, glaube ich, im Februar oder so, wenn die zweite Verkaufsphase war, und kriegst das Geld dann erstattet, wenn dein Team die Runde nicht erreichen sollte. Das heißt, ich kriege jetzt das Geld fürs Finale, kriege ich erstattet. Fürs Halbfinale, ja, hätte ich die Karten nicht abgeholt, würden sie dann morgen früh noch liegen irgendwo in Marseille an unserem Ticketschalter. Ich habe sie natürlich abgeholt und habe zwei Twitter-Kollegen glücklich machen können.
Ja, das ist doch auch, das ist doch schön. Allein dafür haben sich die 40 Euro Mitgliedsbeitrag doch gelohnt. Das kann ich dir sagen, Tobias.
Fand ich auch.
Matthias, du hast ja schon gesagt, du warst eher dann auf dem Last-Minute-Markt unterwegs. Wahrscheinlich habt ihr euch da wahrscheinlich auch mal getroffen, ohne es zu wissen.
Möglicherweise anonym, ja.
Wie lief denn dann so diese letzte Verkaufsphase? Ich habe immer wieder Tweets gelesen, dass es dann unter dem Strich gar nicht mehr so schwierig war, an Tickets zu kommen. Es wirkte ein bisschen so, als wäre sogar der Schwarzmarkt zusammengebrochen. Ich habe gelesen von teilweise Tickets für einen Zehner oder für 15 Euro.
Ja, das habe ich auch mitbekommen. Also das war dann tatsächlich gar nicht mehr so schwer. Hing natürlich ein bisschen von der Begegnung ab. Also ich habe auf diesem Last-Minute-Markt vor der EM – das war ja so eine Zwischenverkaufsphase, wenn man so will – also irgendwie vier, sechs Wochen bevor ich nach Paris gefahren bin, habe ich da schon mal mehr für ein paar Spieler die Tickets besorgt, unter anderem Island gegen Österreich, da war es relativ leicht, da waren so sieben, acht Spiele im Verkauf noch, da wo es einfach noch Tickets gab, das viel zitierte Rumänien, Albanien natürlich dabei. Und dann habe ich mich einfach von Paris aus während der Vorrunde einfach mal aus reinem Interesse eingeloggt in diesen Ticket-Shop, weil ich mal gucken wollte, was sich das jetzt so tut, ob es überhaupt noch Tickets gibt. Und dann fand ich da für den nächsten Tag oder für den übernächsten Tag Schweden gegen Irland im Start der Franzen. Ich habe gedacht, da versuchen wir es nochmal. Und es war super einfach. Ich war innerhalb von einer Minute eingeloggt, hatte keine Wartezeit und nichts. Dann habe ich sofort dieses Ticket bekommen, was ich dann wollte. War also gar kein Problem. Bei den Spielen dann in der K.o.-Phase war es ein bisschen schwieriger. Ich habe zwei Achtelfinals gesehen, Schweiz gegen Polen, relativ problemlos. Da wurde es allerdings so von der UEFA gelöst, dass es immer ab 14 Uhr am Tag dieses Portal freigeschaltet war. Also vormittags konnte man nicht. Es stand immer drauf, wir öffnen um 14 Uhr. Dann konnte man sich um 13.45 Uhr ungefähr in eine Warteschlange einreihen. Das hat dann noch meistens bis viertel Nacht, zwei, halb drei, gedauert, bis man auf dem Portal war. Dann konnte man sich dann zu den Partien durchklicken, die noch da waren. Das war ein bisschen auf gut Glück. Der Status zwischen ausverkauft und es sind noch Tickets da, wechselte gefühlt alle fünf Sekunden, weil immer irgendwelche Tickets wieder auftauchten. Ich habe dann Schweiz-Polen, wie gesagt, relativ problemlos bekommen. Ich habe Italien, Spanien ein Ticket bekommen. Da habe ich ungefähr 30, 40 Mal versuchen müssen und habe 35 mal gelesen, es war ausverkauft, bis ich dann doch durchgekommen bin mit einem Ticket. Das einzig nervtöntende daran ist, man muss sich bei jedem Mal, wo man sich wieder auf dieses Spiel bewährt, muss man wieder sagen, nein, ich bin kein Roboter und ich weiß, ich kann dieses Bilderrätsel, was ihr mir zeigt, zu sagen, auf welchem Bildfluss zu sehen ist, oder so, irgendwann später auswendig schon klicken. Das habe ich unzählige Male gemacht und am schwersten war es dann tatsächlich Viertelfinale Deutschland-Italien. Da habe ich eine Dreiviertelstunde immer wieder die Seite aktualisiert, bis ich dann schließlich mal eine Karte bekommen habe. Das war dann verhältnismäßig leicht, aber sobald die Spiele irgendwie dann prominent besetzt waren, war nichts zu machen. Also französische Spiele, überhaupt keine Chance. Halbfinale, so gut wie keine Chance. Und Deutschland-Italien, wie gesagt, mit viel Mühe, aber doch im Endeffekt verhältnismäßig leicht, wenn man sich eben das vorstellt, dass es ja schon diese verkaufsfasenden Jahr vorher gab.
Ich kretschle mal ganz kurz rein, Matthias. Du hast 13.45 Uhr gesagt, also das Ding war wirklich 13.45, Doppelpunkt 0-0. Also es ging da wirklich um Sekunden, wenn du um 13.45 und zwei Sekunden drin warst, bist du erst um 14.10 Uhr ins Portal gekommen. Warst du um 13.45 und 0-0 Sekunden drin, warst du dann tatsächlich einer der ersten und konntest um 14.00 Uhr direkt shoppen gehen und auch teilweise sogar noch Spiele Kategorie 4 kaufen, also so Viertelfinale für 45 Euro und solche Geschichten. Ich habe das gemacht tatsächlich beim Spiel gegen Frankreich, beim Halbfinale in Marseille, saß in der Hotellobby und hatte zwei Karten für den Frankreich-Block in Kategorie 3 und da wollte ich eigentlich nicht hin. Also ich wollte schon irgendwie gerne so auf die Deutschlandseite und das war halt mitten im Frankreich-Block und habe dann tatsächlich noch in letzter Sekunde zwei Karten für den Deutschland-Block Kategorie 3 Sichtbehindert bekommen. Die waren auch wirklich Sichtbehindert. Es war ja, man musste halt stehen, aber das war in dem Spiel jetzt nicht so das Drama. Dann hat man sich dann so ein bisschen, wenn man sich groß gemacht hat, ging es auch oder halt gestanden hat oder auf andere Plätze gesetzt hat, funktionierte das. Aber diese Last-Minute-Dinger um 14 Uhr immer waren tatsächlich immer ein Highlight. Ja, muss ich sagen. War eine gute Idee von UEFA und da gingen wirklich nochmal die allerletzten Tickets über den Tisch. Und das hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Und ich habe gelernt, dass meine Uhr falsch gelaufen ist und ich tatsächlich immer ein paar Sekunden zu spät war, weil ich war nie vor Viertel nach 2. weltzeit.org Ich habe es mir gemerkt.
Mein Gott, da tauschen sich jetzt echt die Experten aus. Aber das hört sich ja für mich ehrlich gesagt so an. Also, da gab es relativ viele Möglichkeiten, sich über den digitalen Weg dann Tickets zu holen. Gab es denn dann eigentlich noch diesen klassischen Ticket-Schwarzmarkt, den man bei jedem Bundesligaspiel erlebt?
Also, beobachten konnte man das. Ich habe es auch am Stade de France eigentlich am fast intensivsten beobachtet. Wenn man da in Saint-Denis am Bahnhof aus dem Nahverkehrszug gestiegen ist, dann standen sie quasi den ganzen Weg bis zum Stadion. Ticket, Ticket, Ticket, Ticket, hat man immer nur gehört. Das war dann von Spiel zu Spiel unterschiedlich. Ich habe tatsächlich auch bei einem Spiel mitbekommen, dass da Karten, die irgendwie Kategorie 1 oder 2 waren, also wo wir über 100 Euro Kategorie, 150 Euro Preise geredet haben, dass die tatsächlich nur noch für 15, 20 Euro weggegangen sind, weil einfach die Nachfrage dann nicht so da war. Das war dann zum Beispiel bei der Partie Island Österreich so. Bei Deutschland Italien sah der Fall, glaube ich, ein bisschen anders aus.
Das deckt sich mit meinen Erfahrungen. Sautigny, tatsächlich genau dort, der Weg von einer Bahn bis zum Stadion, alle zwei Meter stand eigentlich einer. Sowohl bei Deutschland – Quatsch bei Deutschland – bei Italien gegen Spanien, beim Achtelfinale, da waren es ganz, ganz viele, da war der Preis ganz, ganz weit unten. Aber auch – und das fand ich persönlich dann wirklich schockierend – Deutschland gegen Frankreich. Also es hat eigentlich keiner, der auf dem Schwarzmarkt eine Karte gekauft hat, das bezahlt, was auf der Karte drauf stand. Da spielt der Gastgeber in einem Halbfinale in einem unfassbar schönen Stadion gegen Deutschland. Also ich meine, das ist nun auch nicht das kleinste Land, und die haben viele Leute, die da hinfahren. Und es gibt auf dem Schwarzmarkt Karten bis zum Umfallen. Also sowohl in der Altstadt oder beim Alten Hafen, da war eigentlich so der Hauptticketmarkt, da standen die Leute. Manche waren so, die zischten immer so Ticket, Ticket. Manche haben die Dinger einfach gnadenlos hochgehalten und war denen egal. Polizei war es eigentlich auch egal.
Ja, das war überhaupt total egal.
Auf dem Weg zum Stadion überhaupt kein Problem. Ticket, Ticket, Ticket. Überall gab es Karten. Also, wer da die aufgedruckten Preise vielleicht Kategorie 4 mal ausgenommen hat, so eine Halbfinale, Kategorie 4, 65 Euro, das hat wahrscheinlich schwierig geklappt. Aber Kategorie 3, 165 Euro hat eigentlich keiner bezahlt, was auf der Karte drauf stand, der es auf dem Schwarzmarkt gekauft hat. Auch eine Sache, die ich natürlich vorher nie gedacht hätte, die ich jetzt gelernt habe, die hilft mir nicht mehr weiter, weil nächstes Turnier, neue Regeln, gar keine Frage. Aber das war erschreckend, das war teilweise Polen gegen Portugal, das Viertelfinale in Marseille, wo ich war Zehner, Zwanzig, keine Ahnung, Marseille, ich weiß nicht, 60.000 passen da rein, 65.000 oder so. Es waren viele Polen da, es waren relativ wenig Portugiesen da, und du kommst vor dem Stadion, kannst du dich mitkarten, das war Wahnsinn. Also, ja, das war wirklich erschreckend teilweise. Und Deutschland gegen Frankreich war dann so der Gipfel der ganzen Geschichte, wo ich dachte, wow, für so ein Spiel noch so viele Karten hier und keiner kauft sie. Aber gut, Kategorie 1 kostet beim Halbfinale 500 Euro. Wer bezahlt das schon?
Und meinst du auch, dass das der Grund ist, dass es diese Karten noch gab? Weil würde mich ja schon interessieren, woran das liegen könnte.
Also natürlich, die UEFA hat durch die hohen Preise, haben sie quasi den Schwarzmarkt, wahrscheinlich unbewusst, weil sie natürlich als erstes an ihre Tasche gedacht haben, haben sie den Schwarzmarkt so ein bisschen zerstört. Also du siehst ja sofort, wenn du da so in der Nähe des Stadions bist, oder in Marseille am Alten Hafen, oder in der Nähe von irgendeiner Fernmeile, du erkennst ja sofort die Leute, die das professionell machen. Das sind nämlich dann immer die mit der kleinen Umhängetasche. Oder du erkennst die, die halt eine Karte über haben, weil einer abgesprungen ist, weil er nicht konnte, weil er krank geworden ist oder was auch immer, und die dieses Ding einfach nur loswerden wollen. Und diese beiden versuchen sich natürlich zu treffen. Und der Händler, der sagt dann zu dem Typen, der eine über hat, ja, ich gebe dir für deine 295 Euro Halbfinale Karte in Kategorie 2, gebe ich dir 40 Euro. Dann fängt der andere an zu weinen, dann diskutieren die ein bisschen hin und dann einigen sie sich am Ende auf 80. Und dann hat der Händler eine Karte mit 300 Euro Wert für 80 Euro aufgekauft. So, und wenn er die für 150 verkauft hat, ist er natürlich glücklich. Und kein Mensch zahlt dir die 295 Euro zurück. Wirklich ein todtrauriges Bild. Da waren in Marseille am Hafen, standen zwei jüngere Damen, die hatten sich ein Schild gebastelt, wir verkaufen vier Karten Kategorie 1. Die kostet 495 Euro das Stück, also 2000 Euro. Ich habe tatsächlich mit denen gesprochen. Ich sag, wie kommt ihr zu vier Karten? Ja, die hatten sich beworben und hatten angeklickt. Du konntest ja bei der UEFA damals, bei der ersten, auch bei der zweiten Verkaufsphase sagen, wenn ich die Karten nicht in der Kategorie bekomme, die ich gerne hätte, nehme ich auch eine Kategorie höher oder tiefer. Das war in Anführungsstrichen der Genickbruch für viele Leute, die dann in Kategorie 1 gespült wurden und Karten für 500 Euro oder Stück gekriegt haben. Warum die Leute da nicht mitgekommen sind, keine Ahnung, sie hat es mir erzählt. Ach, lange Geschichte, spielt ja auch letzten Endes keine Rolle. Entscheidend war, die hatten 4 Karten für 2000 Euro und die Leute sind ihre Karten für 165 Euro nicht los geworden für den Preis, der drauf steht. Ich weiß nicht, wie deren Geschichte geendet ist, aber ich hoffe für sie, dass sie für die 4 Karten irgendwie noch 500 oder 600 Euro bekommen haben und damit dann zumindest abends noch einen, weiß ich nicht, einen schönen Weißwein trinken konnten.
Wahnsinn. Und das eigentlich Bittere der UEFA hat es ja trotzdem nicht geschadet, denn die hat ja einmal den vollen Preis gezahlt bekommen. Das heißt, eher eine Entwicklung, die dann runtergesteckt wird. Na gut, aber schwierig einzugrenzen. Auch schwierig abzuschätzen wahrscheinlich, wie sich das jetzt dann weiterentwickeln wird.
Ich kann es dir sagen, die Weltmeisterschaft 2018 in Russland, die Karten, da gibt es nicht eine für 25 Euro, zumindest wenn man nicht russischer Staatsbürger ist.
Genau, da gibt es diese Russlandklausel.
Genau, die Russlandklausel, da gibt es die günstigsten Karten, glaube ich, für 18, 19 Euro. Stand jetzt, wenn man das den Rubel in Euro umrechnet. Aber für nicht russische Staatsbürger bist du bei 95 Euro für eine Vorrundenkarte in der günstigsten Kategorie.
Ja, aber da muss man zur Verteidigung auch sagen, dass Russland auch wirklich näher liegt als Frankreich und nicht so weite Reisewege hat.
Genau, da sind ja ganz viele da. Also nur auch zu der Frage, wie geht die Geschichte weiter? Also auf jeden Fall nicht gut.
Eine von vielen Entwicklungen, die ein bisschen auf eine merkwürdige Zukunft hindeuten. Was sind denn eure Überlegungen dazu, Matthias? Du kannst mal vielleicht anfangen. Warum auch bei manchen hochklassigen Spielen das Interesse geringer war? Meinst du, dass da vielleicht auch der Aspekt Sicherheitslage mit reinkam?
Ich glaube, im Vorfeld war das sicherlich ein Thema während des Turniers. Ich habe mich auch gerade mit der Fragestellung so ein bisschen auch durch das Land bewegt und auch meine Beobachtungen versucht, immer in diese Richtung so ein bisschen zu machen. Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass das Thema von Woche zu Woche oder fast schon von Tag zu Tag geringer wurde in Frankreich, dass man sich da immer weniger Gedanken zugemacht hat. Und spätestens als dann in Marseille beim Spiel England Russlands die Hooligan-Ausschreitung gegeben hat, ist das Thema Terror-Sicherheit total in den Hintergrund gerückt. Kleine Anekdote dazu, offizielle Abschlusspressekonferenz der UEFA im Stade de France. Kein einziges Mal fiel das Wort Terror. Kein einziges Mal fiel das Wort Sicherheit vor Anschlägen. Da wurde nur allgemein gedankt den Sicherheitsbehörden. Es wurde aber in vielen Fragen der Journalisten auch darüber geredet, was da die Konsequenzen von Marseille sind. Also das Thema Sicherheit war glaube ich höchstens im Vorfeld ein Thema. Dann ein zweiter Grund, den ich mir vorstellen könnte, was vor allen Dingen Frankreich angeht, war die Begeisterungsfähigkeit der französischen Fans. Das ist ein bisschen anders als in Deutschland, habe ich definitiv so festgestellt. Hab auch mit vielen Fans darüber gesprochen, was das für Ausprägungen hat und wie man das erklären kann. Also es war ja so, dass die französischen Fans eigentlich erst mit dem Halbfinale wach geworden sind. Also Fanchen an den Autos, null in Paris. Hab ich kein einziges gesehen. Fanchen an den Häusern, bis einschließlich Viertelfinale, ja, vielleicht eine pro Straße. Das wurde dann zum Halbfinale ein bisschen mehr. Also in der kleinen Straße, in der ich gewohnt habe, war an einem Haus dann vor dem Halbfinale vier Fanchen zu sehen, wo vorher, glaube ich, eine hing. Aber die Begeisterung war da nicht so. Und es war dann auch ein bisschen durch den Spielplan geschuldet. So eine Art Eventkultur, weil der Spielplan ja vorgesehen hat. Frankreich hatte sein erstes Spiel an einem Freitag. Dann das zweite Spiel unter der Woche. Klar, ging nicht anders. Das dritte Gruppenspiel gegen die Schweiz war an einem Sonntag. Das Achtelfinale war an einem Sonntag. Das Viertelfinale war an einem Sonntag. Das heißt, die haben immer nur sonntags gespielt. Und es war dann so echt so eine Art Eventkultur. Also sonntagsmittags, wenn man durch Paris gegangen ist, dann hat man die Trikots gesehen. Dann gingen die auf die Fernmeile, guckten das Spiel, gingen fünf Minuten nach dem Anpfiff wieder nach Hause und am Montagmorgen war nichts mehr zu sehen davon. Kein Trikot in der U-Bahn, kein Trikot auf den Straßen, keine Fanchen, nichts. Natürlich die Überschrift in den Zeitungen, das ist klar. Aber das ist ein bisschen andere Fan-Kultur. Und da haben die Fans auch dann so was zugesagt. Ja, wir gehen jetzt hier hin und wir genießen das Spiel und dann ist es auch wieder gut. Und einer, auch der Verantwortlichen der Stadt Paris, der hat mir nachher gesagt, das ist so ein bisschen französische Mentalität, wir halten zu den Siegern. Und wir feiern erst dann, wenn wir den Titel haben und dann lassen wir es aber krachen. Das spielt sicherlich eine Rolle. Und dann spielt noch die Rolle, dass im Frankreich es ja viele soziale Probleme gibt, viele wirtschaftliche Probleme. Es gibt diese Proteste, die zum Teil auch Richtung Fan-Meile gezogen sind, die sich gegen die Reformen und Gesetze im Land richten, die Ungerechtigkeiten da anprangern. Es hat ja die Streikprobleme unmittelbar vor dem Start gegeben, sowohl bei Müllabfuhr als auch beim Nahverkehr. Und da hatten viele Franzosen, also ich habe viele O-Töne im Ohr, die gesagt haben, wir haben einfach keinen Bock auf diese Europameisterschaft. Wir haben wirklich wichtige Probleme. Und dann kann uns ein Fußballturnier mal richtig gestohlen bleiben. Und ich glaube, dass das so eine Mischung aus dem allen war, die dann dazu geführt hat, dass auch so ein Spiel wie Frankreich-Deutschland eher nicht so den Anklang gefunden hat.
Hat sich das denn dann auch im Stadion wieder gespiegelt? Also das hört sich jetzt dann ja auch nicht so an, als ob ich als ein Franzose, der vielleicht in einem Spielort lebt oder in der Nähe mir dann mal so ein Spiel wie Kroatien gegen Portugal einfach mal angucke, so wie man es ja zum Beispiel bei der WM 2006 habe ich das in meinem persönlichen Umfeld und auch bei mir selbst schon erlebt, dass man sich da total gefreut hat, egal welches Spiel man sehen konnte.
Also ich habe es jetzt nicht beobachtet, dass da jetzt wer weiß, wie viele Franzosen irgendwie Väter mit ihren Kindern oder Familien oder Freundeskreise irgendwie hingegangen werden. Das hat man einzeln gesehen, aber jetzt nicht irgendwie Hunderte oder so. Und das waren dann eher Menschen, die dann zu einer bestimmten Mannschaft gehalten haben. Also ich habe neben mir sass zum Beispiel ein Franzose, der ein Italien-Trikot getragen hat, der aber Franzose war bei einem Italien-Spiel. Also solche Fans habe ich gesehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob Tobi das auch beobachtet hat, aber so diese, wir wohnen jetzt in Lille oder in Lyon. Und hier ist heute ein Spiel, wer weiß, was ich hier, Deutschland, Slowakei oder meinetwegen Ukraine gegen Nordirland. Und wir machen uns jetzt da einen tollen Tag draußen, gehen mal ins Stadion mit der Familie oder Vater und Sohn, habe ich nicht beobachtet.
Französisch sprechend in Trikots von anderen Ländern habe ich tatsächlich auch ein paar Mal gesehen. Ich muss aber sagen, vielleicht lag es doch einfach an meinen Plätzen, dass ich immer im neutralen Bereich saß, weil über die UEFA gebucht, dass ich doch durchaus öfter Franzosen auch einfach in legerer Kleidung, also ohne sich auf ein Trikot festzulegen, im Stadion gesehen habe, auch Vater mit Sohn oder Dreier- Vierergruppe, da fällt mir dann tatsächlich das Viertelfinale ein. Was war das Viertelfinale? Das Viertelfinale in Marseille, Polen gegen Portugal. Da haben wir nach dem Spiel noch vier Franzosen getroffen, die tatsächlich aus dem ganzen Land zusammengekommen waren. Teilweise sogar noch von Übersee, weil sie dort wohnen aktuell. Und sich dieses Spiel zusammen haben angeguckt, Polen gegen Portugal in Marseille. Und wir haben mit denen nach dem Spiel noch eine halbe Stunde gequatscht. Und das war auch sehr, sehr nett. Der eine war für Polen und die anderen waren eigentlich mehr für Frankreich. Das war doch durchaus ab und zu mal so, dass man auf solche Leute getroffen ist, die Franzosen waren und einfach nur des Fußballwegens da waren. Aber ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass es vielleicht nicht in so großer Zahl war, wie das von Max eben angesprochene 2006-Phänomen, wo ja irgendwie jeder auf Fußballdroge war in Deutschland und sich das dann angucken wollte. Was aber tatsächlich fast überall da war, wo ich war, unabhängig davon, dass Deutschland an dem Tag nicht spielte, waren deutsche Fußballfans. Also das hat man wirklich aus Deutschland dann rüber transportiert nach Frankreich, dass die Deutschen sich jedes Spiel angeguckt haben. Also viele sind da ja dann auch ziemlich schmerzfrei und laufen mit dem Deutschland-Trikot zu, ich weiß nicht, Italien, Spanien, weiß nicht, wo der Zusammenhang ist, aber sie machen es halt, sollen sie gerne tun. Ja, das war ja für mich letztendlich auch Gegnerbeobachtung. Ich muss ja gestehen, ich hatte, wie gesagt, die Route ziemlich viel nach der deutschen Nationalmannschaft geplant, aber dann halt auch die anderen Spiele mitgenommen, wo die Deutschen nicht gespielt haben. Und ich hatte immer das Gefühl, die Idee hatten mehrere, dass Deutschland, wenn sie Zweiter werden, das Viertelfinale in Marseille spielen. So spielte Polen in Marseille als Gruppenzweiter der deutschen Gruppe. Aber das hätte halt auch Deutschland sein können. Und da waren unfassbar viele Deutsche im Deutschland-Trikot und man hat tatsächlich diesen Gesang, die Nummer eins der Welt sind wir, bei Polen gegen Portugal im Stadion gehört. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Ja, geht gar nicht.
Wie war denn dann so deine Einschätzung nach Tobi, die Stimmung vor Ort, die Begeisterungsfähigkeit? Decken sich deine Beobachtungen mit denen von Matthias?
Ja, also ich glaube ja. Wir waren ja wahrscheinlich oft an verschiedenen Orten. Und ich war auch gar nicht so viel in Paris, in der Innenstadt. Aber ich war zumindest zum Finale dann in Paris, Zentrum. Und ja, selbst da war am Samstag. Ach, morgen ist Fußball, ja. Also diese Fähnchen aus dem Fenster hängen oder an den Autos und so. Das war wirklich relativ wenig. Überraschend viel war es an einem Ort, wo gar kein Fußball war, in Clermont-Ferrand. Da hatten wir zwei Tage Aufenthalt nach dem Viertelfinale der Deutschen in Bordeaux. Da sind wir dann rübergefahren nach Lyon zum Halbfinale. Ich mit meiner Frau zwei Nächte da in relativ kleinen – das heißt relativ kleinen – ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele Einwohner die haben, 300.000 oder so. Dort gab es Public Viewing. Und dort saßen die Leute in den Kneipen und Bars und so. Und haben sich das Viertelfinale Frankreich gegen Island angucken. Da waren sie auch wirklich voll dabei und hatten großen Spaß. Okay, es ging 5 zu 2 aus, da hat man halt offline Spaß. Aber das war so eine Sache, wo ich überrascht war. Eine Stadt, die gar nicht Spielort der EM ist. Dort so eine Begeisterung auf viele, viele Fahren und auf den Autos und so weiter zu sehen. Aber sonst würde ich mich da durchaus dem anschließen, was Matthias gesagt hat, so ganz begeistert war der durchschnittliche Franzose, glaube ich, nicht.
Vielleicht kann ich noch ein Wort zu Paris anfügen, weil ich die meiste Zeit in Paris war. Da sind noch zwei Beobachtungen vielleicht zu ergänzen. Also das eine ist, Paris ist einfach eine derart große Stadt, die bekannte Weltmetropole schlechthin. Da geht so ein Turnier einfach auch ein bisschen unter. Also wenn man an der Fan-Meile ist, am Eiffelturm, da war ja das zentrale Fanfest, wo ja 90.000 Fans auch hin konnten zum Public Viewing. Da kam man natürlich nicht dran vorbei. Aber wenn man zum Beispiel auf dem Montmartre gegangen ist, weil es ja auch eigentlich das Vergnügungsviertel von Paris ist, da war zum Beispiel an einem der Abende war da so ein Musikfestival, das musste um die Sommersonnenwende gewesen sein, Midsommernacht. Da war kein einziges Trikot zu sehen auf dem Montmartre. Da waren die Musikfans. Und diese Stadt hat einfach so unglaublich viel zu bieten, dass so ein Europameisterschaftsturnier einfach irgendwie eins von vielen Events ist. Das haben mir auch mehrere Leute gesagt. Der Pariser wählt sich seine Events aus. Heute bin ich auf Kultur, morgen gehe ich zum Fußball und dann mache ich wieder was anderes. Das ist die eine Beobachtung. Und die andere Beobachtung ist, nach den Anschlägen vom November in Paris hat es sehr rigide Sicherheitsvorkehrungen gegeben, was auch Restaurant- und Kneipenbesitzer angeht. Das heißt, es durfte keine Bar, keine Brasserie, einen Fernseher aufbauen, dass man draußen gucken konnte. Also, wenn man Fußball gucken konnte, in der Kneipe ging das nur drinnen. Manche haben sich so halb drüber weggesetzt, indem sie ihren Fernseher dann drinnen ans Fenster gestellt haben. Aber eigentlich war es verboten, dass man draußen gucken konnte, weil die Polizei gesagt hat, das können wir nicht sichern, wenn sich Menschen, Mengen, kleine Klüppchen an Straßenecken vor Fernsehern versammelt. Das ist ein zu einfaches Ziel für potenzielle Terroristen. Deswegen ist das verboten. Und da musste man, wenn man das wollte, ganz, ganz viele Sonderbestimmungen erfüllen, wenn man – ich glaube, die sind auch kaum, zumindest meine U-Bachtung – kaum erteilt worden. Also, das hat sicherlich dazu beigetragen, dass man dann in der Stadt auch so ein bisschen dran vorbeigehen konnte an diesem Turnier. Soweit ich weiß, galt das nur in Paris. Ich hab's in Lyon, da war ich auch einen Abend unterwegs. Da konnte man, glaube ich, zumindest auch so auf Terrassen von Bars auch mal gucken.
Ja, in Bordeaux und in Marseille war das auch völlig normal, dass man dort draußen birgartenmäßig sitzen konnte, die Fernseher dann draußen hingestellt wurden. Also, das scheint eine Paris-Geschichte gewesen zu sein.
Die waren ja auch am meisten getroffen, oder die waren ja die Stadt, die getroffen war. Und da gibt's ja auch einfach unzählige Brasserien. Also, wenn da jeder sein Fernseher aufgebaut hätte, da hast du ja an jeder Straße 50 Möglichkeiten zum Public Viewing. Und das haben die einfach unterbunden. Und das hat sicherlich dazu beigetragen, dass, wenn man durch die Stadt gegangen ist, man einfach nicht so viel davon mitbekommen hat. Also, ich bin bei einem Frankreichsspiel aus der U-Bahn gekommen. Und es war so 5 vor 9. Ich habe dann gehört, dass die Nationalhymne gesungen wird. Aber sehen konnte man keinen Fan. Nirgendwo. Also, ich konnte hören, dass in den Kneipen das gesungen wurde. Und die Wohnung an der Straße, wo die Fenster auf waren, da konnte man den Fernsehkommentator hören. Aber sonst war nichts zu sehen. Kein einziger Fan auf der Straße.
Womit wir nochmal beim Thema Sicherheit sind, da würde ich jetzt auch nochmal kurz bleiben. Wir nehmen am Freitag nach dieser EM auf. Das heißt, wir tun das schon mit dem Wissen, dass in Nizza es zu einem schrecklichen Terroranschlag mutmaßlich oder sehr wahrscheinlich kam. Während der EM allerdings ist nichts passiert. Und das wurde vorher sehr thematisiert. Und ihr habt es ja vorhin beide auch schon kurz erwähnt. Dieses Thema wurde dann schnell ersetzt durch Hooligan. Und dieses Thema wiederum fadete dann so ein bisschen aus, dadurch, dass es keine weiteren Vorkommnisse mehr gab. Zumindest keine, über die medial berichtet wurde. Tobi, wie groß war denn dieses Thema während des Turniers? Wie hast du die Anwesenheit von Sicherheitskräften, wie hast du das empfunden? Gab es da Situationen, die dir dahingehend im Gedächtnis geblieben sind?
Also während des Turniers, also ich muss dazu sagen, du hast das glaube ich ganz am Anfang in der Einladung nicht hundertprozentig richtig gesagt. Ich war nicht vier Wochen vor Ort, ich war eine und dann noch mal zweieinhalb Wochen vor Ort. Also ich war zwischendurch noch mal ein bisschen zuhause.
Das sind ja dreieinhalb.
Da kann man ja wohl aufrunden, Tobi. Das Runden wäre eine ganze Zeit. Also es war tatsächlich so, dass ich zwei Blöcke hatte, in denen ich da war und der erste war die Vorrundengeschichte, wo wir dann vier Spiele geguckt haben mit drei Jungs. Beim ersten Spiel waren wir noch zu viert. Da muss ich schon sagen, auch aus persönlicher Sicht, man ist ja schon so ein bisschen mit einem mulmigen Gefühl an die ganze Geschichte rangegangen. Also ich habe ja gesagt, ich habe vor 13 Monaten das geplant. Damals war Terror in Paris zumindest nicht mit Fußball verbunden. Diese Geschichte im November folgte ja dann erst viel, viel später. Ich habe natürlich auch darüber nachgedacht, hat das irgendwelche Auswirkungen für mich, für meine Reise, für die Pläne, die ich habe. Habe dann gesagt, nein, hat es nicht. Ich mache das trotzdem und auch genauso, wie ich das möchte. Ich hatte dann so ein paar Auswirkungen, was meine Reisepartner angeht. Aber für mich war es irgendwie kein Grund, zu sagen, ok, ich fahre da jetzt nicht hin. Und trotz allem war es natürlich so, gerade in der Vorrunde. Das erste Spiel, das wir gesehen haben, war Deutschland gegen Ukraine. Das war an dem Sonntag in Lille. Das war das erste Spiel in Lille. Man wusste nicht, wie sind die Verhältnisse in Lille. Man hatte die Bilder nur gesehen aus Marseille, wo die Russen und die Engländer sich dort schwerst daneben benommen haben. Und da hatte man natürlich immer im Hinterkopf. Da könnte ja auch noch in der andere Richtung was passieren. Das war schon so ein bisschen, muss ich gestehen, die ersten ein, zwei Spiele. Wir sind danach nach Paris gefahren, in Saint-Denis, waren wir dann im Stade de France. Das gehörte dann auch noch dazu. Also gefühlt war, fühlte man sich, fühlte man sich immer so ein bisschen unwohl. Das ließ aber relativ schnell und im Laufe des Turniers dann auch sehr stark nach. Und war dann irgendwie kein Thema mehr. Und was die Sicherheitsfunktion vor Ort dann ging, ich habe mit mehr gerechnet, muss ich sagen. Also, ich kenne es jetzt letztendlich fast nur aus Hannover. Natürlich bin ich auch in dem einen oder anderen Stadion in Deutschland ab und zu mal unterwegs, oder auch mal in Europa unterwegs gewesen. Aber in Hannover, da gehst du dann halt zur ersten Kontrolle. Da lässt du dich ein bisschen abtasten. Dann guckt der vielleicht mal in deine Rosentasche oder in irgendeine andere Tasche. Und dann gehst du in den Stadion. Ich dachte, okay, bei dieser EM werden die alles auffahren, was sie haben. Da wird es das riesengroße Ding geben. Und man braucht Stunden, bis man drin ist. Wir sind tatsächlich beim ersten Spiel, so wie die UEFA es empfohlen hat, drei Stunden vor Spielbeginn da gewesen. Und haben mit allem gerechnet. Es war dann eine Polizeikontrolle. Die haben in die Rucksäcke geguckt. Und dann gab es die nächste Kontrolle. Die haben geguckt, ob die Karte, die man dabei hat, ob die original ist. Dann gab es noch eine dritte Kontrolle. Da haben sie dann dieses übliche Abtasten gemacht. Das war bei den elf Spielen, wo es von so Klack Klack, gehen sie durch, bis die Hand ganz schön tief in der Hose war. Sie hat geguckt, ob hinter dem Gürtel noch was versteckt ist. Es war alles mit dabei. Es war wirklich weit gestreut. Genauso wie es in der Bundesliga und in der zweiten Liga auch ist. Es kommt immer auf den Menschen an, der dich individuell abtastet. Wie viel Zeit hat der? Wie viel Lust hat der? Wie genau geht er vor? Es war eigentlich, bis auf diese erste und zweite Zone, die jetzt aber auch nicht wirklich intensiv durchsucht hat oder viel gemacht hat, war es letztendlich nichts anderes als die Sicherheitsvorkehrung bei einem 08-15 Bundesliga-Spiel. Also, wenn ich mich da in die letzte Saison erinnere von 1996, das war ähnlich. Da gab es jetzt keine riesengroßen Unterschiede. Was wirklich tatsächlich ein Unterschied war, war die große, große Polizei- und Militärpräsenz um das Stadion herum. Man hat spätestens ab einem Kilometer vorher die ersten schwer bewaffneten Polizisten und Soldaten da. Die haben mit dem Maschinengewehr locker auf der Schulter ungefähr dort gestanden und sich das alles angeguckt. Aber sonst, das, was das Stadion direkt anging, war es gefühlt so wie in der Bundesliga. Das war jetzt kein wirklicher Unterschied.
Matthias, du warst ja auch bei einigen anderen Events, also jetzt nicht nur im Stadion, hast du am Anfang erzählt. Wie war es denn zum Beispiel auf Fan Main? Da warst du doch auch vor Ort.
Ja, also meine Beobachtungen beginnen eigentlich am Tag des Eröffnungsspiels, als ich mit dem Zug von Köln hingefahren bin, mit dem Thalys, und die erste Begegnung mit schwer bewaffneten Polizisten und Militärs in Brüssel hatte, als sechs Mann durch den Zug sind und quasi den ganzen Zug durchsucht haben. In Brüssel habe ich gedacht, hallo, jetzt nähern wir uns Paris und jetzt bin ich wirklich mal gespannt, wie das noch weitergeht. Und in Paris war es dann tatsächlich so, als ich angekommen bin auf dem Bahnhof, unendlich viele Polizisten, unendlich viele Soldaten an jeder Ecke, immer in drei, vier Mann-Grüppchen unterwegs, mindestens einer immer mit einem großen Gewehr oder einer Maschinenpistole umgehängt. Das war absolut respekt-einflößend für mich an dem ersten Tag. Und ich bin dann auch zu einem, direkt zu einem ersten Rundgang gestartet durch Paris und habe mir so ein paar Punkte mal angeguckt. Und egal, wo man unterwegs war, an der Metrostation, an den touristischen Sehenswürdigkeiten, sagen wir mal Louvre, Champs-Élysées, Eiffelturm, Montmartre mit Sacre-Cœur, egal wo man war, überall unglaublich viele Polizeistreifen. Die hatten also, ich habe das Gefühl, sehr viel Angst auch an diesem Eröffnungstag. Und dann bin ich zur Fan-Meile auch gegangen am Eiffelturm und gebe freimütig und offen zu. Ich hatte tatsächlich ein bisschen mulmiges Gefühl, auch vor der Europameisterschaft habe immer gesagt, im Stadion, glaube ich, ist man relativ sicher, weil man das relativ gut schützen kann, durch die Eingänge und durch die Polizei. Aber Fan-Meile, 100.000 Leute auf freiem Feld, Eiffelturm, habe ich Respekt vor. Und da bin ich hin und habe mir das auch genau unter dem Punkt angeguckt. Deutlich mehr Kontrollen am Stadion, war zumindest mein Eindruck. Also man ist erstmal durch so einen ersten äußeren Ring gegangen. Das ist mir jetzt im Prinzip mit dem Hintergrund von Nizza auch nochmal bewusst geworden, dass dieser äußere Ring tatsächlich schon wie eine erste Kontrolle war, weil nämlich dort Polizeivagen, so Mannschaftswagen, so Bullis, wäre und verkeilt auf der Straße standen, dass eben kein LKW da durchfahren kann. Und da standen schon mal an jeder Straße 7, 8, 9 Polizisten, die haben einen nicht kontrolliert. Die haben einen einfach, ich sag mal, angeschaut und geguckt, was kommen denn da für Leute. Und da konnte man eigentlich relativ leicht vorbeigehen. Und dann kam die erste Polizeikontrolle mit erste Rucksackkontrolle und Leibesvisitation, die in unterschiedlichsten Stärken war, so wie Tobi das beschrieben hat, von einmal kurz Beine abklopfen bis hinzu, jetzt dreh dich mal um und ich tasse dich von hinten ab, dass du ja keinen Mist machen kannst, während ich hier dich abtaste. Und dann ging es noch einen Gang weiter, die eigentliche Sicherheitskontrolle, da habe ich auch alles erlebt, von flüchtiger Blick in den Rucksack bis hinzu, jetzt lärst du den Rucksack mal bitte auf dem Tisch aus. Und nochmal Leibesvisitation, also da war ich dann, ich war relativ häufig auf der Fanzone und ich muss gestehen, da habe ich mich sehr, sehr sicher gefühlt im Vergleich zu dem Gefühl, was ich hatte, als ich hingefahren bin nach Paris. Und das hat sich auch nicht geändert über das Turnier eigentlich, da hat es kleinere Zwischenfälle mit Feuerwerkskörpern oder so gegeben, aber das war eigentlich unerheblich. Und an die Militärpräsenz und an die Polizeipräsenz hat man sich ehrlicherweise total gewöhnt. Also, das war einfach klar. Es ist einem schon gar nicht mehr aufgefallen, dass einem mal wieder vier bis an die Zähne bewaffnete Soldaten entgegengekommen sind. Das hat man einfach so hingenommen, das gehört es im Stadtbild und zur Europameisterschaft dazu. Und das ist auch bei den Parisern so. Die sind total daran gewöhnt und das ist alles völlig in Ordnung. Und die wissen auch, dass man manchmal auch auf der Straße einfach kontrolliert wird. Das wissen die Pariser und da wehrt sich auch keiner. Und das ist alles völlig d'accord für alle eigentlich, die da waren. Und das ist relativ entspannt abgelaufen und hat mir dann ein Gefühl von Sicherheit auch vermittelt. Und das hat sich ja dann im Endeffekt auch Gott sei Dank als Wahr herausgestellt, dass da nichts passiert ist.
Ging mir übrigens ähnlich wie dir, Matthias. Fanmeile, ich musste halt nicht hin. Ich hatte da keinen Auftrag. Ich habe tatsächlich bei der ersten Tour einen durchgehenden Bogen drum gemacht. Und da sind wir dann wieder beim Fanclub Nationalmannschaft auf dem Campingplatz des Fanclubs Nationalmannschaft in Paris gewohnt. So ein bisschen außerhalb im Westen, aber grundsätzlich ganz gut gelegen und eine günstige Alternative gewesen zum Hotel. Und haben dort dann die Spiele geguckt und sind nicht reingefahren nach Paris zur Fanmeile, weil wir es halt nicht mussten. Haben wir es dann einfach auch gelassen. Meine ersten Fanmeilenbesuche waren dann im weiteren Turnierverlauf, als ich dann in der K.o. Runde, ich glaube, in Bordeaux waren wir auf der Fanmeile zumindest mal umzugucken, weil da war ja nur ein Spiel, der spielt ja nur Deutschland gegen Italien. Haben wir uns trotzdem die Fanmeile angeguckt.
Wunderschön gelegen auf einem tollen Platz.
Fantastisch, ganz großartig gemacht in Bordeaux. Stückchen besser wahrscheinlich sogar noch in Lyon fand ich. Da liegt es dann auch mitten in der City. Und in Lyon war es tatsächlich so, dass diese Flughafen-Piep-Dinger, wo man so durchgeht, und man gibt seine Metallgegenstände abläuft, dann da durch und dann piept es oder piept halt auch nicht, die gab es in Lyon tatsächlich zur Kontrolle. Ich weiß nicht, wie das abends abläuft, wenn das Spiel war, wir waren nachmittags da oder vormittags, oder gegen Mittag, ist auch egal, waren wir da, haben uns das angeguckt, was da so los ist, weil es dann halt auch erst meine zweite Fan-Meile war, obwohl wir schon im Halbfinale waren. Aber ich muss auch echt sagen, da haben die wirklich einen sehr intensiven Job gemacht. Und ich habe auf diesem Campingplatz in Paris noch eine Geschichte von unseren Nachbarn, die quasi nebenan gewohnt haben, gehört. Die fand ich sehr beeindruckend. Der hat sich bei den fliegenden Händlern, Matthias wird sie kennen, die diese kleinen Eiffeltürme verkaufen. Da hat er sich so einen kleinen Eiffelturm gekauft und wollte dann hinterher leichtsinnig, wie er war, auf die Fernmeile gehen. Und das fand der Typ am Einlass aber überhaupt nicht witzig. Und dann musste er zu diesem Häuschen, da konnte man seine Sachen abgeben. Da hat er diesen Eiffelturm, der war vielleicht 15 Zentimeter oder so, hat er den dort abgegeben, hat sich das Spiel angeguckt und ist nach dem Spiel da wieder hin und wollte den Eiffelturm wieder abholen. Und dachte sich, naja gut, jetzt hole ich den Eiffelturm ab und dann gehe ich hier raus und dann ist gut. Ja, Pustekuchen. Da musste erst ein Ordner kommen, der hat den Eiffelturm in die Hand genommen. Dann ist er mit diesem Bekannten bis zum Ausgang. 100 Meter. Diese Fanmeile war ja riesengroß in Paris. Gelaufen, hat ihn nicht aus der Hand gegeben und hat dann als der Kumpel, die Fanmeile verlassen hat, da hat er ihm den Eiffelturm in die Hand gedrückt und hat gesagt, noch zu seinem Ordnerkollegen, der kommt hier nicht wieder rein mit dem Eiffelturm. Also, die haben sich wirklich schon gerade bei den Fanmeilen sehr, sehr große Mühe gegeben und ich kann voll und ganz verstehen, wenn du sagst, dass du am Anfang Sorgen hattest, aber die quasi mit den Erlebnissen vor Ort dann wieder revidiert wurden.
Ich mache noch zwei kleine Ergänzungen auch wieder, so wie gerade. Ich habe einen Touristen oder einen Fan erlebt, der fast verzweifelt war, weil ihm die Kontrolle seine Powerbank weggenommen hat. Das ist aber auch schlimm. Das ist ein Wurfgeschoss und er sagt, ich habe aber kein Akku mehr und ich muss hier meinen Handy laden und ich brauche das Ding und ich habe keine Bombe bei mir, ich will nur meinen Handy laden und das ist völlig und es war ein riesen Theater mit vier, fünf Ordnern, die da waren. Und eine andere Beobachtung, die deckt sich ein bisschen mit dem, was Raphael Buschmann im Spiegel geschrieben hat, jetzt zum Finale, der ja so ein bisschen mutig versucht hat, die Sicherheitskontrollen zu umgehen und die auch eine Menge geschafft hat, bis hin, dass er in der deutschen Kabine gesessen hat und auf dem Rasen gestanden ist. Es gab einen Tag, ich hatte mein Mikrofon dabei, weil ich ein Interview oder weil ich Fans interviewen wollte auf der Fanmeile und dieses Mikrofon ist ein relativ großer, schwerer Knochen, weil da auch die Aufnahmeeinheit und die Batterien und alles drin ist, also das ist relativ schwer und groß, würde eindeutig auch als Schlagstock durchgehen. Und das war ein Tag, wo es sehr nervös war, weil da Proteste in Paris waren, die in die Nähe der Fanmeile gezogen sind, wegen dieser Arbeitsmarktreform. Und da waren mehrere Eingänge zu an der Fanmeile, wo man gar nicht drauf konnte, aus Sicherheitsgründen, dass die Protestler da gar nicht in die Nähe dieser Eingänge kommen. Ich musste quasi, weil ich genau an der Stelle war, wo ich eigentlich drauf wollte, der war dann gesperrt, einmal um das ganze Marsfeld laufen. Da ist man gefühlt eine halbe Stunde unterwegs, bis man auf der anderen Seite ist. Und bin dann an einen Eingang und habe gesagt, so, ich möchte jetzt hier gerne rein. Und dann sagte die Ordnerin, die meinen Rucksack tatsächlich komplett ausgeleert hat, was ist das? Ja, ein Mikrofon. Nein, geht nicht. Ich sage, ich bin Journalist, ich möchte hier arbeiten, ich bin Interviewsführend. Nein, geht nicht. Müsste hier abgegeben werden an der Deposit-Stelle. Und dann habe ich gesagt, geht nicht, ich möchte hier arbeiten, ich muss Interviews führen. Hier ist meine Akkreditierung, habe meine UEFA-Akkreditierung rausgeholt und ich habe gesagt, ich habe das alle Tage hier gemacht. Überhaupt kein Ding, ich bin also ich möchte hier arbeiten. Nein, geht nicht, sie muss einen Chef holen. Okay, dann kam der Chef und hat gesagt, ich bräuchte eine extra Akkreditierung für die Fanzone. Und ich habe gesagt, die habe ich aber nicht. Ich habe meine UEFA-Akkreditierung und ich möchte einfach hier arbeiten, Interviews führen. Nein, das funktioniert nicht. Ich könnte das jetzt abgeben oder ich könnte nach Hause gehen oder ich könnte es an einem anderen Eingang versuchen. Und dann habe ich gesagt, okay, dann gehe ich zum anderen Eingang. Und da hat der Kollege gesagt, was ist das? Ich habe gesagt, Mikrofon.
Aber, glaube ich dir, genau so haben es fast alle Leute gemacht. Und diese Powerbank-Geschichte vor mir glaube ich vier bis acht Mal bei elf Spielen erlebt, dass in der Schlange beim Kontrollieren die Leute ihre Powerbank nicht mit reinnehmen durften, weil sie zu groß war, weil sie überhaupt eine Powerbank war, keine Ahnung. Ich habe mir tatsächlich vor dem Turnier eine gekauft, die von der Fläche her so groß ist wie eine EC-Karte und dann halt, weiß ich nicht, so dick wie sechs EC-Karten, die kannst du ins Portemonnaie packen. Es hat nicht einmal einer ins Portemonnaie geguckt. Dementsprechend hatte ich die Powerbank immer mit im Stadion. Aber tatsächlich ist die Lösung, gehen sie zu einem anderen Eingang, ist die einzige, die dich dann auch wirklich in solchen Situationen dahin bringt, wo du hinmöchtest. Aber natürlich auch die bösen Jungs dahin bringen, wo sie hinmöchten.
Ja, das ist vielleicht nur ein interessanter Punkt. Da kam nämlich auch eine höhere Frage. Denn das eine ist ja die Sicherheit der Fanmine und der Zone rund ums Stadion. Und Matthias hat es ja schon angesprochen, ein Stadion selbst, wenn man innen drin ist, da hat man nochmal gewisse Sicherheitsmechanismen schon überwunden, die andere nicht so leicht überwinden können. Und dennoch kam es jetzt auch bei dieser EM dazu, dass Bengalos geschmissen wurden, zum Teil ja sogar. Es gab Böller, es gab Leuchtraketen und ein bisschen ein anderes Thema, aber auch die vielen Flitzer haben zumindest in meinem Umfeld für einiges verwundern gesorgt. Wie empfandet ihr denn die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen innerhalb der Stadien und kann man da den Veranstaltern überhaupt einen Vorwurf machen? Denn mir ist keine Liga dieser Welt bekannt, die es hinbekommt, Bengalos, Böller und ähnliche Dinge aus Stadien fernzuhalten.
Ich finde, 100 Prozent abhalten kann man das nicht. Ich habe es im Stadion selber nur ein paar Mal gesehen, dass dann nach einem Tor irgendwie so eine Fackel hochgehalten wurde. Das war jetzt auch irgendwie alles nicht dramatisch, aber man hat es natürlich trotzdem gesehen. Ich habe es einmal auf einer Fanzone gesehen. Da war, ich glaube, es war Türkei gegen Kroatien. Da hat es ein bisschen so eine kleine Schubserei gegeben und da wurde ein Böller gezogen. Da waren wir kurz Hallo auf der Fanzone. Da war auch ein bisschen Bewegung. Aber da haben die Sicherheitskräfte sofort reagiert, diesen Böller unter den nächsten Bauzaun geschoben und da war sofort wieder Ruhe. Also da haben sie auch super reagiert. Ich habe einen Bericht gelesen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das auch in dem Spiegelbericht von dem Raphael Wuschmann war. Ich glaube, dass bei diesem Spiel, wo es diese schlimmen oder in Anführungsstrichen die schlimmsten Ausschreitungen mit Feuerwerkskörpern gab, das war ja Kroatien gegen Tschechien, wenn ich mich recht erinnere. In Zhajtien war das, glaube ich, auch, dass da die schon am Tag vorher ins Stadion gebracht wurden, also dass die schon quasi über Nacht da waren und dass sich die Fangruppen quasi Schlachtpläne gemacht hatten, richtig mit detaillierten Verlaufsplänen, an welchem Eingang sie was mit reinbekommen und wo der sicherste Eingang ist. Und das sind halt die Dinge, die dann einen so ein bisschen beunruhigen, dass da so generalstabsmäßig das vorbereitet werden kann, dass man das so generalstabsmäßig auschecken kann, wo es am leichtesten geht und sich da sogar Pläne schreiben kann. Also das ist, finde ich, das, was mich beunruhigt, dass dann mal ein Feuerwerkskörper im Stadion ist oder mal so eine Fackel da gezündet wird bei dem Tor.
Du kannst es halt nicht ändern. Also ich habe ja gesagt, du wurdest mal so, mal so abgetastet und 100 Prozent kriegst du da niemals raus. Was mich im Stadion fast schon schockiert hat, ich glaube, es war Rumänien gegen die Schweiz, als die Rumänen das 1-0 geschossen haben. Wir saßen auf der Seite der Schweizer und hatten den Blick dann dementsprechend im Prinzenpark auf die Seite der Rumänen. Und man konnte ganz klar sehen, da gab es viele Blöcke, die für die Fans vorgesehen waren. Und dann gab es einen Block, der direkt daran anschloss. Dort waren nur schwarzgekleidete junge Männer, sage ich jetzt mal, so im Schnitt. Also man konnte das aus der Ferne relativ gut sehen. Die gehörten zu den Rumänen, hatten keine Trikots an. Und als die Rumänen dann das 1-0 geschossen haben, in der 18. Minute, wo brannten natürlich die Pyros, genau in dem Block. Also die hatten komplett diesen ganzen Block für sich alleine, hatten auch die Ordner drum herum stehen. Und dann zünden die diese Pyros an. Und ich weiß ja nicht, in Hannover ist es zumindest Standard. Dann brennt das Ding ab. Und dann ist das Thema auch in Ordnung. Und dann werfen die das weg. Bei dem Turnier sind die Ordner in den Block rein und haben denen die brennenden Pyros aus der Hand gerissen. Also, ich weiß nicht, das haben die sich ja wahrscheinlich nicht ausgedacht, die Ordner. Also, wenn die einigermaßen beigegangen sind, machen sie das ja nicht. Das muss ja also eine Ansage gewesen sein. Ich hab's noch bei irgendeinem anderen Spiel, ich krieg's jetzt nicht mehr zusammen. Ich glaube, es war Polen gegen Portugal, das Viertelfinale in Marseille, auch beobachten können, dass dort brennende Fackeln aus der Hand gerissen werden. Und dann irgendwie möglich so, dass man sie nicht sieht hinter irgendwelche Banden oder rausgebracht oder wie auch immer, je nachdem, in welchem Bereich des Steilungs das ist. Das fand ich schon ziemlich extrem. In meinen Augen sehr leichtsinnig, aber die werden schon wissen, was sie tun. Ich hoffe zumindest, dass sie wussten, was sie tun. Die Ordner in dem Moment. Das war so eine Beobachtung aus dem Stadion, wo ich dachte, wow, ganz unangenehme Geschichte. Matthias, du hast es ja wahrscheinlich auch gesehen, dass man mit Seilen gearbeitet hat im Innenraum. Ganz großartig. Ich musste immer lachen.
UEFA 2016-Style.
Du möchtest natürlich verhindern, dass irgendwelche Flitzer in den Stadion-Innenbereich kommen.
Dann spannt sie ins Seil oder was?
Du hast dann natürlich die Ordner positioniert und während du spielst kannst du nicht auf einer, weiß ich nicht, wahrscheinlich 400 Meter langen Bahn alle 10 cm einen Ordner hinstellen. Also stellst du alle drei oder vier Meter einen hin und die haben einen Seil in der Hand. Das halten die in der Hand und dann geht das wieder runter und beim nächsten Ordner geht das wieder hoch. Und in dem Moment, wo einer versucht, da durchzubrechen, versuchen sie das Seil halt hochzuziehen und damit den Flitzer zum Straucheln oder zum Erliegen zu bringen. Ich habe, glaube ich, zwei oder drei Flitzer live gesehen im Stadion, sind aber immer auf der anderen Seite des Stadions abgehauen. Deshalb kann ich nicht sehen, was sie mit diesem Seil tatsächlich veranstaltet haben. Ich kann es mir nur so erklären, dass sie versuchen, mit diesem Seil mehrere Flitzer aufzuhalten und so quasi zum Straucheln zu bringen. Das sah immer ein bisschen unbeholfen aus.
Aber diese Seile sind ja auch noch für einen anderen Zweck eingesetzt worden. Das kommt man immer kurz vor dem Anpfiff beobachten. Ein Bild für die Götter, muss man sagen. Da wurden Podeste aufgebaut für die Fotografen, damit die die Mannschaftsfotos machen konnten und dann eben das Einlaufen der Mannschaften aus dem Kabinengang. Und diese Podeste standen quasi am Rand der Coachingzone. Es wurden so kleine Podeste hingestellt, wo dann sich die, weiß ich nicht, 35 Journalisten, 35 Fotografen auf jeder Seite drauf färchen konnten, um da diese berühmten Mannschaftsfotos für die Sonderhefte zu knipsen, wo die elf Spieler alteinander stehen. Und die Journalisten wurden dann immer, das war ja ein unglaubliches Zeremoniell, mit dieser Eröffnungsfeier vor jedem Spiel. Und dann wurden die Journalisten durch einen, oder die Fotografen durch einen, durch einen Seiteneingang rein geführt. Und zwar immer in einem Pulk zusammen. Und rund um den Pulk wurden, liefen sechs Ordner. Und die hatten drei Seile gespannt. An jeder Seite eins und vorne quer eins. Damit keiner von den Fotografen es wagte, auszubüxen und alle schön in den Pulk, genau zu dem Podest geführt werden konnten. Und dann durften die auf das Podest drauf und ihre Fotos machen. Und danach wurden die schön wieder weggeführt und hatten ja dann alle ihre Sitze rund um die Banden, dass sie dann die Hintertorfotografen und die, was weiß ich, wo die alle sitzen. Das war absolut lächerlich, weil das sind professionelle Kollegen, die machen da ihre Arbeit. Von denen hat keiner irgendwie Interesse, ein Stück Rasen rauszuschneiden oder sonst irgendwas zu machen. Die wollen einfach nur möglichst schnell einen guten Platz auf diesem Podest haben, um da ihr Foto zu machen, was sie an die Agitur verkaufen oder in ihrer Zeitung. Und die müssen da zwischen Leinen laufen, damit sie ja nicht irgendwie einen halben Meter zu weit. Absolut lächerlich.
Immer wieder ein schönes Bild.
Und im Nachhinein weiß man, man hätte diese Leinen eher um die Kinder Jugendlichen machen sollen, die damit beschäftigt waren, die großen Trikots aufzuspannen und das große UEFA-Logo zu drehen. Da kamen ja dann die Selfie-Jäger her, die Cristiano Ronaldo noch geknipst haben.
Ja, aber ich finde gerade er ist ja auch ein Beispiel dafür, wie man das gut mit Humor nehmen kann.
Absolut. Wie ist denn das, wenn man David Guetta so, ich würde mal sagen, in 30 Tagen gefühlt 15, 16 Mal auf voller Lautstärke hört?
15, 16 Mal? Das ist der Tagesration!
Das schallt ja überall her, auf der Fan-Meile überall. Also ich bin ganz ehrlich, es ist überhaupt nicht meine Musik. Ich finde aber, jetzt mal ganz ehrlich gesprochen, dass der Schlussteil seiner Musik, die dann immer gespielt wurde, als die Mannschaften reinkamen, wo er seine Musik irgendwie in fast schon was pathetisches verwandelt hat, irgendwie hatte das was. Ich weiß nicht, was es hatte, aber irgendwie hatte das was. Man hat sich irgendwie dann aber dann einfach dran gehört und das dann so beim spätestens dritten Mal, ja, das war halt so und das war halt die Erkennungsmelodie. Man wusste genau, was jetzt passiert. Und da man diese Eröffnungsfeier, die ja auch immer gleich waren bei jedem Spiel, man konnte die Schritte ja quasi auf der Tribüne schon mittanzen, beim dritten Mal. Das war ja alles ein absolut überbordendes Zeremoniell fast schon. Aber um bei David Guetta zu bleiben, irgendwie hatte seine Musik was, aber es ist einfach nicht meine.
Du weißt nicht genau, was.
Meine ist auch nicht, aber so für ein- zweimal Gänsehaut hat es gereicht.
Okay.
Vielleicht lag es nicht zwingend an ihm, sondern einfach an meinem ersten EM-Spiel oder dass es Halbfinale war oder was auch immer. Aber es war schon nicht so ganz schlecht organisiert und geplant von UEFA. Und da muss man auch wirklich diese ganzen Kinder, ob sie dann uns Selfies machen oder nicht, aber das Getanze und so. Man kann das schlechter machen. Und ich finde, es wird ja auch immer gerne und auch völlig zu Recht über Eröffnungs- und Abschlussfeiern gemeckert. Eröffnungsfeier habe ich nicht gesehen, da war ich noch zu Hause und habe es auch im Fernsehen tatsächlich nicht gesehen. Aber die Abschlussfeier, das war doch, das war kurz und knackig und da hat man nicht mehr gemacht als nötig. Und man hat auch wirklich erst ein Viertel von Neun angefangen, so wie bei allen Spielen sowieso auch. Ja, es gehört so ein Stück weiter zu, aber ich fand es insgesamt nicht so schlecht gemacht. Ich würde aber vor noch ganz kurz gerne noch mal Max den Schwung zurück zur Sicherheit machen. Eine Geschichte, die ich noch zwingend loswerden muss, das war das Halbfinale in Marseille, Deutschland gegen Frankreich. Ich glaube, die Franzosen, ich weiß nicht, wann haben sie das 2-0 geschossen? Das muss irgendwie so in der 75. Minute gewesen sein. Ich kriege es gar nicht mehr zusammen. Ich möchte mich auch vielleicht gar nicht daran erinnern. Und dann sind meine Frau und ich kurz mal noch was trinken und auf Toilette gegangen und dachten uns, okay, vielleicht geht gleich noch mal was. Wir waren dann quasi hinter der Tribüne, da ist ein relativ großer Bereich gewesen, wo man sich frei aufhalten konnte. Aber auch der Zaun, der geschlossen war und eine Tür offen hatte, von vielleicht 10, 15 Türen, die die Leute in- und aus dem Stadion rausließen. Aber offensichtlich war der Zaun nicht weiter bewacht. Es sind tatsächlich in der 75. oder 80. Minute Leute per Räuberleiter in dieses Stadion eingebrochen. Und da hat keiner drauf geachtet. Also der Tag war sowieso so ein bisschen verkorkst, was die Organisation anging und was die Sicherheit anging. Wir mussten nicht wie beim ersten Spiel in Marseille über die Seite, wo die Hauptstraße war, sondern über so eine Nebenstraße rein. Da lief man dann irgendwie gefühlt noch mal eine Stunde, bis man um 22 Häuserblöcke rum war, um dann auf der anderen Seite vom Stadion zu sein. Dort hatten die Ordner eine Reihe aufgemacht, wo man dann die Leute quasi gebremst hat und dann immer blockweise reingelassen hat, damit die dann kontrolliert werden konnten. Das brach dann auch irgendwie um 20.20 Uhr oder so komplett zusammen, und man ließ dann alle Leute auf diese kontrollierenden Ordner zustürmen, die natürlich auch nicht mehr intensiv kontrolliert haben. Also das war so der erste Fail oder nicht ganz geglückte Move von den Sicherheitskräften. Und das wohlgemerkt beim wahrscheinlich fünften oder sechsten Spiel in Marseille. Das war jetzt nicht so, dass die erstmalig so ein Spiel da hatten, sondern das letzte und das Halbfinale dort. Ja, und dann hatten wir diese Szene in der 80. Minute, wo vier Leute auf der anderen Seite vom Zaun standen. Und wie das bei Rollball halt so ist, drei haben es geschafft. Einer ist dann nicht mehr reingekommen. Der hatte keinen, der ihm über den Zaun helfen konnte. Aber die anderen drei, die waren im Stadion. Eine davon hatte eine relativ große und beeindruckende Umhängetasche um. Also so ein Bag zum Umhängen. Gut, offensichtlich hatte er da nichts drin. Aber ich fand es schon erschreckend, dass das überhaupt möglich war, dass die Leute da relativ easy und – das ging vielleicht anderthalb Minuten oder so – in diese Stadion eindringen konnten.
Das ist tatsächlich – ja, interessant ist noch das neutralste Attektiv, was mir dazu einfällt. Ein bisschen bedenklich tatsächlich.
Bedenklich, ja.
Eine Sache kann man noch hinzufügen. Sainte-Denis, Viertelfinale, Frankreich, Island, auf einmal Riesenauflauf. Polizei, gepanzerte Autos, die mit quietschenden Reifen um die Ecken schießen. Ich wollte gerade den Presseeingang nehmen, weil ich eigentlich zu einer Pressekonferenz wollte, die da vor dem Spiel war, und ich durfte nicht weitergehen. Man hat mich angehalten, also jetzt nicht irgendwie, dass es irgendwie gefährlich war, sondern gesagt, jetzt warte mal kurz hier, hier müssen wir gerade mal durch. Und dann sind da sieben, acht, neun, zehn Autos in vollstem Tempo, zum Teil mit absolut verdunkelten Scheiben, vermummte Polizisten an mir vorbei. Ich habe dann nachher gehört, da musste ein Auto gesprengt werden. Ich habe gedacht, das hat man, glaube ich, gar nicht so mitbekommen in Deutschland. Im Endeffekt hat sich das als völlig harmlos herausgestellt, er hatte im Parkverbot gestanden. Und man hat gedacht, das könnte was sein, und dann hat das Auto einfach kurz sein gesprengt.
Füge ich noch meine Geschichte vom Finale dazu. Ich glaube, die gleiche Situation hatte sich abgespielt beim Spiel Deutschland gegen Polen. Da gab es zumindest auch in Deutschland ein Video, was ich gar nicht weiß, von welcher Zeitung er war. Ein Journalist, der hinter der Absperrung stand, da hat man nicht ein Auto, sondern einen Roller gesprengt. Und jetzt beim Finale, Portugal gegen Frankreich, war es dann wieder so, als ich von der Bahn zum Start gegangen bin, auf einmal gab es das große Gehupe und Gefeifer von der Polizei. Man möge sich bitte möglichst schnell dort von dem Ort entfernen. Und da stand dann auch an einem Baum auf diesem Weg ein einsamer, herrenloser Roller. Und die Polizei hat das ratzefatze abgesperrt. Ich weiß nicht, wie die Geschichte ausgegangen ist. Ich habe mich dann schnellstmöglich verdrückt, weil ich mir dachte, es muss ja auch nicht sein. Es ist ja dann auch mehr zum Spaß hier. Wie die Geschichte ausgeht, spielt keine Rolle. Aber die Lunte war sehr, sehr kurz gerade um Start de France herum. Da kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass ein oder andere Roller oder das eine oder andere Auto das Zeitliche gesegnet hat, obwohl er überhaupt nichts Böses gemacht hat.
Ja gut, da werden wahrscheinlich alle zustimmt nicken, wenn man sagt, lieber einmal zu viel vorsichtig sein. Man mag sich, glaube ich, den organisatorischen Aufwand allein an Personnell gar nicht so richtig vorstellen, wie viele Sicherheitskräfte da unterwegs waren. Und jetzt umso makaberer natürlich, dass jetzt direkt nach der EM Frankreich wieder getroffen wird. Das ist sicher auch so kein Zufall. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie ich wollte eigentlich mit euch jetzt über das ganze Prozedere innerhalb des Stadions sprechen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man da den Bogen hinbekommt, ohne allzu pietästlos zu sein. Ich erspare mir mal den Gag, den ich dazu auf den Lippen habe. Einfach, es war ja immer derselbe Ablauf, immer nach festem Protokoll. Für mich als Fernsehzuschauer hatte es den großen Vorteil. Ich habe immer eigentlich bis zum Anpfiff noch gearbeitet oder irgendwas im Haushalt gemacht. Ich hatte immer nur die Vorberichterstattung auf den Ohren. Und so ab, ich glaube, bei CDF war es so, immer nach dem letzten Werbebreak, bevor es dann losging, war die Stadionatmoschule hinterlegt, hinter die Experten. Und dann konnte ich schon anhand der Tracks, die gespielt wurden, erkennen, okay, jetzt sind es noch fünf Minuten, okay, jetzt sind es noch drei Minuten. Aber jetzt kommt der David Guettart-Teil, der mir übrigens auch gefällt. Jetzt drehen sich gleich die Stour dessen von Fly Emirates, war glaube ich der Sponsor, drehen sich gleich und dann kommen die Spieler rein. Okay, jetzt sollte ich dann auch wieder zurück ins Wohnzimmer. Wie empfindet man das denn, wenn man im Stadion ist?
Also, fange ich kurz an. Ich habe vorhin angesprochen, ich bin tatsächlich beim ersten Spiel, wie die UEFA es gerne hätte, drei Stunden vor Spielbeginn in der Nähe des Stadions gewesen, noch nicht im Stadion. Aber man legt das dann sehr schnell ab. Also, ich glaube, man kann da fast eine Gerade ziehen nach oben. Und zum Finale war ich um 20.55 Uhr oder 20.50 Uhr auf meinem Platz und habe mich dann das ganze Drama da angeguckt. Also, ich weiß nicht, man nimmt das halt so mit. Also, ich hatte ja dann, ich weiß nicht, wer es bei Twitter verfolgt hat. Meine Sammelleidenschaft wurde geweckt, als ich den ersten Spieltagsbecher in der Hand hatte. Und da wurden dann am Ende 11 Spieltagsbecher drum. Das heißt, das war immer noch so die Aufgabe, bevor das Spiel losging, dass ich diesen blöden Becher organisiert kriege. Das war nicht immer ganz leicht. Gerade ab Achmelfinale gab es dann halt nicht unendlich von diesen bedruckten Bechern mit den Flaggen drauf. Da war es dann immer ein bisschen schwierig. Aber hat alles immer gut geklappt. Und ich sag mal so, ab Achmelfinale war ich, glaube ich, nie vor 20.30 Uhr im Stadion. Ich habe also diese ganzen Shishis da vorher mir komplett gespart. Und diese 20.45 Geschichte, ja gut. Man musste sie halt mitnehmen. Da ging es nicht anders.
Bisschen zur Kiss-Cam in der Halbzeit dann, ne?
Da waren teilweise wirklich schöne Sachen dabei. Also, das hat man ja offensichtlich aus Amerika geklaut. Das gibt es ja schon seit gefühlten 100 Jahren. Ich finde, da hat man in der Halbzeitpause für gute Stimmung gesorgt.
So grundsätzlich hat er ja auch so ein ewiggleiches Protokoll. Nicht nur seine Nachteile. Was ich übrigens bei den Tanzchoreografien sehr bemerkenswert fand war, dass das zumindest im Anschein nach keine professionellen jugendlichen Tänzergruppen waren, sondern ich hatte den Eindruck, da war von Körper, Größe, Umfang und Alter bei den Jugendlichen so ziemlich alles dabei. Die tanzten auch zum Teil so ein bisschen aus der Reihe. Das Gegenbild ist so ein bisschen, finde ich, die Olympischen Spiele, die Eröffnungsfeier in Peking damals. Da hat man 80.000 Menschen, die exakt gleich sogar dieselbe Frisur haben. Das fand ich aber sehr angenehm, muss ich sagen. Dass ich zumindest da den Eindruck hatte, da durften einfach viele Jugendliche mitmachen, die da drauf Lust hatten und die wurden jetzt auch nicht monatelang gedrillt. Dass das auch wirklich alles genau intakt ist, das fand ich eigentlich ganz schön, muss ich sagen.
Ich fand es auch charmant, muss ich sagen. Ich habe keine Hintergründe, ich habe es auch nicht näher recherchiert, wie es jetzt dazu kam, wer da wann, warum, wie tanzten durfte. Aber tatsächlich Männlein, Weiblein, jung, alt, klein, groß, etwas fülliger, etwas dünner, alles war dabei eigentlich. Das habe ich auch so gesehen.
Das war in der Tat positiv, das sehe ich auch so. Sie haben ja dann auch immer das Publikum mit einbezogen, sind dann auf die Auslinie quasi, einmal rundrum haben sie sich verteilt, haben dann gewunken oder getanzt oder wie auch immer. Ich fand auch, das war einfach nett, das passte so ganz gut dahin. Wenn man schon irgendwas in die Richtung macht, dann lieber tanzende Kinder als Menschen auf rollenden Segways.
Ja gut, das ist ja eh klar. Der Segway unterlegt eigentlich jeder Fortbewegungsvariante. Vielleicht beim Hoverboard gibt es ein knappes Unentschieden. Was haben sich denn die Sponsoren so einfallen lassen? Ich bin mir sicher, sie haben sich was einfallen lassen.
Oh ja, Sponsoren ist ein heikles Thema bei dieser Europameisterschaft. Das ist aus mehreren Gründen heikel, wie ich finde. Vor allen Dingen natürlich wegen der Großsponsoren der UEFA. Da sind ja einige dazugekommen, die in fragwürdigem Licht erscheinen. Ich nenne nur ein Beispiel der aserbaidschanische Stromkonzern Soka, der bei jedem Spiel auf den Banden prangte. Da muss jetzt auch mal kurz deutlich werden, wie UEFA wieder ihr typisches Scheuklappenphänomen anlegt. Sie ist natürlich gefragt worden auf der Abschlusspressekonferenz, was sie denn nun von der Menschenrechtssituation in Aserbaidschan halten und was das nun soll. Auch in dem Hinblick, dass 2020 bei der interkontinentalen, oder sagen wir UEFA-weiten Aserbaidschan liegt ja nicht mal auf europäischem Gebiet, Europameisterschaft, was sie da von der Menschenrechtslage halten. Und da gibt es den klassischen Satz, den sie immer sagen, wir reden über Fußball, alles andere interessiert uns nicht. Ich finde, da müssen sie sich tatsächlich Fragen gefallen lassen. Und das ist wieder ganz typische UEFA. Und das kann man auch FIFA, IOC und wie sie alle heißen dazu nehmen. Das ist einfach das typische Funktionärsgehabe. Da ist die UEFA kein Deut besser als irgendjemand anders. Das ist die eine Geschichte. Eine andere Geschichte ist nicht ganz so gefährlich und nicht ganz so dramatisch. Ich hatte es vorhin schon mal angesprochen, diese Beleuchtung des Eiffelturms. Jeden Abend wurde unter den Mannschaften, die an dem Tag gespielt haben, quasi eine Verlosung gemacht. Und der, der die meisten Erwähnungen auf den Social Media Kanälen hatte, in dessen Landesfarben wurde der Eiffelturm angestrahlt. Das war in der Rekordzahl natürlich Frankreich. Die haben an allen sieben Spieltagen hat der Eiffelturm in französischen Farben gebrannt oder geleuchtet. Außer am Achtelfinaltag, da haben die Deutschen das Rennen gemacht. Das war das einzige Mal, dass es in schwarz-rot-gold war. Die Türken hatten es glaube ich viermal oder dreimal. Da war es allerdings einmal, wurde das aus Solidaritätsgründen wegen des Anschlags in Istanbul gemacht. Das war am Anfang so ein bisschen, sagen die Verantwortlichen, selber eine lahme Veranstaltung. Das hat ein bisschen gebraucht, bis die Leute das verstanden haben. Und dann wurde es eigentlich Kult. Dann haben sich die Fans tatsächlich um 11 Uhr nochmal auf der Fan-Meile versammelt, um das zu sehen und dieses Spektakel zu erleben, wenn der dann in den Landesfarben angestrahlt wird. Es ist wirklich technisch einwandfrei gelöst. Schwarz-rot-gold empfiehlt sich jetzt nicht ganz dafür, weil einfach der halbe Turm schwarz ist. Das ist bei einem Nachtbild nicht so ganz toll. Aber insgesamt extrem beeindruckend, super klar angestrahlt, echt tolle Bilder, die man auch sehen kann im Internet. Das ist aber natürlich eine Sponsor-Aktion, ist ja mal ganz klar. Ich habe da ein bisschen recherchiert, habe auch den Sponsor getroffen. Das ist der größte französische Telefonkonzern. Und die haben ein Konzept aufgelegt, man musste, um damit die Stimme gezählt wird, sowohl den Stromkonzern, add Orange, anschreiben in dem Tweet und dann noch den Hashtag Orange, oder dann auf Englisch Orange Sponsors You. Das heißt, in jedem Tweet, der da gezählt wurde, wurde gleich zweimal der Sponsorname genannt. Also absolut perfektes Marketing, würde ich mal sagen. Und sie haben – ich war kurz vor dem Finale da, da hatten sie schon, weiß ich nicht, wie viele Milliarden – nicht Milliarden, Millionen – Erwähnungen und waren mit Abstand der meistgenannteste Sponsor der Europameisterschaft in den sozialen Medien. Ist ja natürlich klar. Aber sie haben alle großen, super Sponsoren, die man da kennt, gab es nun Bankenversicherungen, Bierkonzerne oder sonst was sind, haben sie mit weitem Abstand geschlagen. Also ein Riesenerfolg. Die Stadt Paris wertet es auch als Erfolg, weil sie haben nämlich nichts dafür bezahlt für die technische Umsetzung. Die Fans haben sich gefreut, weil es ein tolles Ereignis war und wenn man da gerade mal die eigene Fahne gesehen hat. Aber im Endeffekt ist das auch einfach ganz geschicktes Marketing.
Ja, definitiv.
So, mal als kleine Geschichte am Rand.
Da ist ja sowieso die UEFA sehr stark drin. Es gibt Bannmeilen, die sich in verschiedenen Kilometergraden um die Stadien ziehen. Ich glaube, mich zu erinnern, dass fünf Kilometer rund um ein Stadion herum keine anderen, keine fremden Sponsoren mehr auftauchen dürfen in Sponsoren, also in Sponsorenart. Also ich glaube, eine Mercedes-Benz Filiale wird dann jetzt nicht dichtgemacht und umgebrandet. Aber es dürfte da eben keine Aktion stattfinden. Wie ist denn das, wenn man sich in diesem vollkommen auf diese paar UEFA-Sponsoren reingewaschenen Bereich bewegt, Tobi? Nimmt man das überhaupt noch wahr? Fährt einem auf, dass man da das immer selbe Bier trinkt? Hatte das Bier überhaupt Alkohol in sich?
Ich habe tatsächlich drei oder vier Bier bei elf Spielen im Stadion getrunken. Wir können den Sponsor ja sagen. Das ist Karlsberg. Und Karlsberg hat im Stadion 0, 5% Alkohol im Bier. Also ein Zehntel von dem, was ein normales Bier hat. Zum Betrinken, wenn das Spiel schlecht ist, absolut ungeeignet. Es schmeckte leider auch absolut ungeeignet. Das war überhaupt nicht mein Geschmack. Ich bin Gott sei Dank relativ schnell auf. Und jetzt muss ich gestehen, ich weiß nicht, Turtle Twist, Turtle Twist, Tuchtel Twist, keine Ahnung, wie das Ding heißt. Das kostete dann, da sind wir natürlich auch beim Preis, also so ein Karlsberg kostet im Stadion, je nachdem, wurde bis zwischen 6, 50 und 7 Euro. Das war so die Preis-Bande, die ich erlebt habe. Schmeckte dann, wie eben beschrieben, ein halber Liter in einem durchschnittlich attraktiven Becher, der ohne Pfand war, also man kriegt dann nicht noch einen Euro zurück. Und ich bin dann auf dieses Turtle Twist oder wie auch immer es heißt, gestoßen. Das ist ein All-Star, also Bier mit Brause oder wie heißt es im südlichen Raum? Ah, Radler. Ein Radler, aber mit alkoholfreiem Bier, also das hatte dann nicht 0, 5% Alkohol, sondern 0, 0%, schmeckte aber relativ gut. Also ich hab's dann irgendwann auch im Supermarkt gefunden und da schmeckt es aus der Dose eigentlich auch ganz nett. Ist ein Erfrischungsgetränk letzten Endes. Es hat mit Bier relativ wenig am Hut. Das ist ja bei All-Star und Radler leider immer so, aber man konnte es eigentlich ganz gut trinken, wenn man jetzt nicht eine Cola oder ein Wasser haben wollte. Von daher, für 5 Euro im Stadion, jetzt nicht die schlechteste Alternative. Und ich muss sagen, Wasser, Cola und die ganzen anderen Sachen da, Fanta und sowas, 4 Euro im Stadion, bei der EM, fand ich jetzt persönlich nicht so schlimm. Ist ein fairer Preis in meinen Augen. Also das kriegst du wahrscheinlich in fast kein Bundesligastadion für den Kurs. Zumal die Becher halt umsonst waren und man musste sie auch nicht zurückbringen. Man konnte sie dann in irgendwelche Sammelbehälter geben und solche Geschichten. Das war, ich muss sagen, relativ überraschend positiv. Essen war sehr vielfältig. Also nicht im Sinne von in einem Stadion gab es verschiedene Sachen, sondern wo du warst, also in Bordeaux gab es Pizza, im Stadion, im Karton, das fand ich ganz nett. Wirklich so, du hast dann halt den, wie als wenn der Lieferdienst es dir gebracht hat, hast du dann mit einer einen Platz genommen.
Was war auf dem Pizza-Karton drauf? War der auch gebrandet mit dem Spiel und dem Flak?
Wir haben keine Pizza gegessen. Ich kann es dir ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen, was drauf war.
Das wäre ja mein Mitbringsel geworden, wenn da irgendwas drauf gestanden hätte vom Spiel. Das finde ich sehr zentral.
Ich glaube, es war nicht gebrandet. Also wie gesagt, ich kann es leider nicht sagen. Ich habe einen Hotdog. Wir sind ja dann natürlich auch nicht ganz doof und wissen, wann es in den Stadion geht. Und dann isst ihr halt vorher was, weil wer mag schon das, was es im Stadion gibt. Also es gab in Liora die Pommes roh. Die Pommes habe ich gar nicht gegessen. Ich habe, glaube ich, einmal oder zweimal so einen Hotdog und einmal so einen Sandwich gegessen, weil der Hunger einfach unfassbar groß war. Die Sandwiches sind halt so wie die Sandwiches an den Rastplätzen oder wo auch immer. Die liegen da seit – na ja – nicht erst seit fünf Minuten in der Regel und sind halt kalt. Da ist dann Schinken und Käse oder was auch immer drauf. Und die Hotdogs liegen da wahrscheinlich auch nicht erst seit fünf Minuten. Es ist halt kein kulinarischer Ruhm.
Essen mit Geschichte.
Du isst es halt, damit du satt bist und damit du vielleicht nach dem Spiel noch in Ruhe ein Bier trinken kannst, was nicht direkt ins Blut geht oder so, sondern sich erst mal mit dem Essen noch ein bisschen arrangieren kann. Ich esse halt auch in Bundesligastadien und so. Das war jetzt nicht besser oder schlechter, fand ich. Also die Pizza war wirklich mal ein Highlight, aber das durchschnittliche Bundesligastadion hat ungefähr das gleiche Niveau wie so ein EM-Stadion. Ansonsten muss ich sagen, wenn du raus bist aus dem Stadion, mir fällt da jetzt immer als erstes Bassey ein, weil das Stadion relativ gut in der Innenstadt liegt, im Gegensatz jetzt zu Saint-Denis oder zu Lille oder auch zu Lyon.
Lyon ist ja der absolut weiteste Weg für mich.
Lyon sind schlanke 13 Kilometer draußen. Absolut furchtbar. Und damit ist der absolute Wahnsinn da draußen. Da gibt es halt auch nichts. Aber in Marseille zum Beispiel, von unserem Hotel, das waren so anderthalb Kilometer, eine Straße geradeaus zum Stadion auf der linken und rechten Seite, da gab es Restaurants und Bier und die haben natürlich dann auch direkt an die Straße verkauft, die haben ihre Fässer dahingestellt, zwei rechts und links in den Stuhl und da drüber noch ein Tresen oder so und haben dann für, je nachdem, wie nah man im Stadion war, irgendwas zwischen fünf und acht Euro, haben sie dann in einem halben Liter Bier an der Straße verkauft. Also das war gar nicht so UEFA reglementiert, wie ich es erwartet hätte. Das war dann tatsächlich immer nur direkt im Stadionbereich, da gab es dann Probleme. Oder wie halt in Lyon zum Beispiel, wo du 13 Kilometer außerhalb bist, da gibt es dann halt nichts. Da wartest du, bis du im Stadion bist und dann kannst du da die eben angesprochenen, leckeren 0, 5 Kalsberg trinken.
Und wie war das jetzt mit jenen Sponsoren, die jetzt nicht für Essen und Trinken zuständig waren? Also, Matthias hat es ja schon angesprochen, unter anderem Sokka. Gut, dass du den Namen nochmal gesagt hast. Den Namen hätte ich nämlich schon nicht mehr mir in Erinnerung rufen können. Vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht. Ich wusste aber noch, Aserbaidschanisches Energieunternehmen staatlich geführt. Das heißt, der Staat gibt da mal wieder Geld aus, wo er an anderer Stelle auch vorgibt, keines zu haben. Und man muss sich nicht lange erkundigen, um herauszufinden, mit welcher Art Staat man es bei Aserbaidschan zu tun hat. Also das kann man sehr, sehr kritisch sehen. Und es gibt dann natürlich auch die Frage, die sich stellt. Moment mal, ein aserbaidschanischer Energiekonzern staatlich geführt. Warum geben die überhaupt so viel Geld aus? Ich glaube, ich habe sogar bei euch Matthias einen Beitrag gehört, von dem ich glaube, 94 Millionen Euro hatte ich abgespeichert. Oder vielleicht waren es sogar – nee, jetzt will ich keine falsche Zahl nennen. Also auf jeden Fall ein hoher Betrag. Haben die denn auch vor Ort etwas getan, um den Zuschauern im Gedächtnis zu bleiben? Oder kann man vielleicht sagen, dadurch, dass die nur über Bande aktiviert haben, dass das vielleicht eher so ein Ding war, um im europäischen Markt ein bisschen bekannter zu werden und vielleicht eher auch Touröffner bei einigen Entscheider-Positionen. Und es ging da gar nicht jetzt darum, irgendwie den Fans klarzumachen, dass es da ein ganz tolles Energieunternehmen gibt.
Also ist mir jetzt nicht untergekommen. Ich weiß nicht, wie es Tobi geht. Also da ist mir jetzt nicht irgendwie offensive Werbung untergekommen. Aber das war ja auf den Banden schon relativ deutlich zu sehen. Ich weiß nicht, wie es auf Fernsehbildern war im Stadion. War es absolut, kam man gar nicht dran vorbei, weil die auch noch, ich glaube, schwarz war die Bande ja. Also absolut prominent zu sehen. Und ich glaube, es ist tatsächlich eine Art Türöffner und der Wegbereiter für 2020, wenn wir dann in Baku die Spiele haben. Das ist schon, glaube ich, jetzt ein Schritt einfach gewesen, die weiteren Folgen dann.
Muss ich mich anschließen? Also ich habe auch unabhängig, ja, abgesehen von diesen Essen-Trinken-Geschichten, auch rund um Stadion, weiß nicht, wenn man sich da jetzt vorstellt, da gibt es einen, weiß ich nicht, einen, wer ist der Autosponsor? Hyundai, Auto oder so, keine Ahnung, was ich dann streicheln kann und ein Foto machen kann, habe ich zumindest nicht wahrgenommen. Vielleicht bin ich da auch schon so abgestumpft, dass ich einfach dran vorbeilaufe und es mir egal ist. Auf den Fan-Milen gab es irgendwie so eine Foto-Boxen, ich glaube mit Coca Cola oder so, wo man dann irgendwelche tollen Fotos machen konnte und auch irgendwelche, wie ja so, so hoher Schuss-Dinger oder dann flog der Ball auf dich zu, du warst der Torwart, ich weiß jetzt aber auch nicht mehr, welcher Sponsor da dahinter steckt. Also da gab es auf den Fan-Milen gab es des Öfteren so ein paar Geschichten, wo ich gedacht habe, okay, das ist jetzt ganz klar ein Sponsor zuzuordnen, der hier irgendeine Geschichte verkaufen will und dann wahrscheinlich, wenn du das gespielt hast oder mitgemacht hast, drückt er dir noch den Flyer in der Hand, damit du dir dann das Auto oder was auch immer noch angucken kannst. Aber im Stadion selber, ich glaube, da galt vielleicht einfach wirklich nicht noch mehr Probleme ins Leben rufen als nötig und jeden, den wir hier reinlassen, den müssen wir kontrollieren und das ist Arbeit und das ist unnötig. Da wurde halt Essen, Trinken verkauft, aber danach hört es zumindest, was meine Wahrnehmung aktuell angeht, komplett auf.
Ich glaube, um mal auf Zucker zurückzukommen, die haben, glaube ich, einen der Preise gesponsort. Ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt der Jugendspieler des Turniers war, also irgendwie für irgendeinen Preis sind die da noch als Sponsor quasi…
Das müsste ja dann die Leuchte des Turniers gewesen sein eigentlich.
Ja, irgendwie sowas. Aber am meisten zu sehen, tatsächlich hat sie gerade angesprochen, Orange, der Telefonkonzern, der Französische, die haben ja auch noch bei jedem Spiel den Fan of the Match gekürt. Ich weiß nicht nach welchen Regeln die den ausgewählt haben. Auf einmal prangte irgendwie so ein Foto von einem Fan, der nicht mal im Stadion sein musste und der war dann der Fan of the Match. Also die waren für…
Und da haben wir den Matthias kurz mal verloren.
Dann können wir vielleicht noch ganz kurz die McDonalds-Fußball-Exkorte oder wie die hießen einwerfen. Die scheint ja in Deutschland ganz große Nummer zum Finale gewesen zu sein, weil da ja ein deutsches Kind, ich weiß gar nicht, ob Mädchen oder Junge, mitgelaufen ist. Habe ich natürlich nicht mitgekriegt vor Ort, aber in Deutschland scheint das ja ein ganz dickes Ding gewesen zu sein.
Ja, es gab nicht so viel, über das man berichten konnte und dann konnte man sich freuen, mein Gott, wir hatten einen Einlaufkind oder Auflaufkind.
Ich glaube, Auflauf ist falsch. Wie auch immer, aber Auflauf müsste falsch sein.
Was mich ja noch interessieren würde, wie sehr geht einem der Countdown auf den Nerv oder feiert man das eher, weil man ja tatsächlich auch selbst die ganze Zeit aufs Spiel hin fiebert. Also ich meine, den Countdown, der zum Amt für Finn heruntergezählt wurde.
Ging mir gar nicht so auf die Nerven. War tatsächlich für mich mehr so eine Erinnerung, mal ganz kurz das Handy rauszuholen. Es gibt gleich einen Anstoß. Du kannst ein schönes Foto machen. Mitgeschrien habe ich ihn, glaube ich, auch nicht. Also, nee. Ich war immer relativ nüchtern und relativ beieinander, als ich in den Stadien war. Deshalb, nee, ich glaube nicht, dass ich da irgendwie mitgegrölt habe und von 10 auf 0 runtergezählt habe. Er ist ja, Herrgott, vielleicht braucht man es einfach. Also, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht freut sich auch der Typ in der Regie, dass er sagt, oh, jetzt weiß ich, jetzt muss ich wieder aufpassen oder so. Was sollen sie machen? Ich bin da wirklich schmerzfrei, was solche Geschichten angeht.
Hat beim ZDF fast geklappt beim Halbfinale.
Ja, das habe ich auch gehört, dass das irgendwie nicht so ganz funktioniert hat.
Nee, nicht so ganz.
Insgesamt weiß ich nicht. Dann sollen sie halt so einen Counter machen. Solange sie mit zehn Sekunden auf den Sack gehen, ist es doch relativ harmlos oder nicht?
Ja, nö. War eine ergebnisoffene Frage. Matthias, du bist uns kurz verloren gegangen. Was wolltest du noch loswerden?
Ich bin, weiß ich gar nicht, bin ich im Satz zusammengebrochen. Mitten im Satz. Ich war glaube ich bei Orange, oder?
Genau.
Ich wollte nur sagen, die waren für mich die präsentesten mit ihrer Farbe, weil sie ja allein wegen der orangenen Farbe und dann mit dem Fan of the Match, der ja nicht mal im Stadion war, unbedingt, wo ich nicht gar nicht weiß, nach welchen Kriterien der ausgewählt wurde. Also die waren für mich einer der präsentesten Sponsoren dieser Europameisterschaft.
So, dann würde mich jetzt noch interessieren, mal so ein bisschen auf die einzelnen Nationen einzugehen, die da waren. Da fällt mir zuerst ein, dass ja jede Nation ihren eigenen Stadionsprecher oder Stadionsprecherin mitbringen durfte. Die Spanierin habe ich persönlich noch in eigener Erinnerung. Die hat mich so ein bisschen an den Vorsänger bei den Eintracht Frankfurt Ultras erinnert, ehrlich gesagt. Tobi, wer war denn da der angenehmste und der schlimmste Vertreter, den du live erlebt hast?
Boah, manchmal gibt es Fragen, wo ich denke, Max, das hätte sie mir mal vor sagen können. Da muss ich mich doch darauf vorbereiten. Nee, keine Ahnung. Krieg ich nicht.
Dann hast du keine prägende Erinnerung.
Ja, genau. Ich erinnere mich natürlich daran, dass der Deutsche Deutsch gesprochen hat und dass der dann auch dieses schwarze Weiß angekündigt hat von Oliver Pocher, was gar nicht mehr Oliver Pocher gesungen hat, wenn mich nicht alles getäuscht hat im Stadion. Da gibt es scheinbar eine neue Version. Aber nee, da gab es jetzt eigentlich keinen, der besonders positiv oder besonders negativ aufgefallen ist bei den Stadionsprechern.
Matthias, hast du da jemanden oder ist das vielleicht…
Ich erinnere mich vor allen Dingen dran, dass ich gar nicht das Gefühl hatte, dass von jedem einer da war. Also bei manchen Spielen hatte ich das Gefühl, da ist nur von einem Land irgendwie einer da. Oder vielleicht habe ich mich auch total verguckt, aber das ist meine Erinnerung. Und ich erinnere mich daran, dass der, der am einundig präsentesten war von seinem Auftreten bei den Spielen, die ich gesehen habe, der österreichische war, der richtig da Party gemacht hat und richtig die Fans angeheizt hat. Und auch diese, ich sage mal, eher geschäftsmäßigen Zwischenkommentare, also in der 78. Minute hat die österreichische Mannschaft ausgewechselt, das ist ausgeschieden, bla bla bla, dass er das dann, ging ja auch um einiges für Österreich, dass er das noch versucht hat, mit Anfeuerungen zu verhindern. Also jetzt geht's nochmal und jetzt zeigt er mal, was er könnte und zehn Minuten. Und also der ist mir in Erinnerung geblieben, weil der halt da seine Show gemacht hat und seine, seine Anheizungsmethoden angewendet hat und nicht nur dem klassischen Sprech da verfallen ist.
Es ist ausgeschieden, ja, dann letztlich komplett Österreich. Und wie war es jetzt bei den Fans? Wir haben auch hier in Deutschland viel natürlich über die irischen Fans mitbekommen, nordirische Fans, über die valisischen Fans. Es kreist sich schon ein über die isländischen Fans. Was mich jetzt mal interessieren würde, vor allem, weil wir mit Tobi jemanden dabei haben, der bei fünf deutschen Spielen war. Wie sind denn die deutschen Fans so organisiert und sagen es technisch unterwegs? Bei mir am Fernsehen kamen nur an, die Nummer eins der Welt sind wir. Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland. Sieg, Sieg, Sieg. Mexiko von den Onkels.
Und scheiß Italiener.
Genau und scheiß Italiener. Erdeckt sich der Eindruck mit dem von vor Ort, dass die deutschen Fans nicht so wirklich organisiert sind und auch nicht so wirkliches Liedgut haben, was gesungen wird.
Wer nicht hüpft, ist kein Deutscher oder irgendwie so in der Richtung. Das gab es auch noch. Aber dann wird es bei mir echt dünn, mit den Ideen, was da noch gab. Die Sieggeschichte, natürlich zu Recht, oft kritisiert.
Ist es im Stadion auch so? Also am Fernseher kriege ich tatsächlich manchmal im Negativen eine Gänsehaut. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine Sensibilität ist, die vielleicht auch so ein bisschen zu einer Political Correctness entspricht. Ist das vor Ort tatsächlich auch so oder empfindet man das vielleicht gar nicht so, wenn auch drum herum andere Dinge geschrien werden?
Genau. Das ist es eben. Also am Fernsehen weißt du ja nicht, wie viele Prozent der Leute es tatsächlich singen. Da sind wir wieder bei, ich hatte viele Spiele an Plätzen, wo es halt neutrale Bereiche sind. Da hast du natürlich gerade mit Deutschland gespielt, zum Beispiel im achten Finale gegen die Slowakei. Da waren ja die neutralen Bereiche wahrscheinlich zu 60, 70 Prozent mit deutschen Fans. Aber da hast du vielleicht einfach ein bisschen andere Fans und da sang das halt keiner. Also da hat halt auch keiner von der Nummer eins der Welt gesungen und da hat auch keiner das Sieg laut mitgeschrieben, was ich insgesamt erfrischend selten gehört habe. Also wir haben es gehört und natürlich hat man es auch am Fernsehen gehört, aber ich fand, es kam relativ selten, was vielleicht auch einfach daran lag, dass wir gar nicht so viele Spiele gewonnen haben. Ich muss sagen, es ist wenig Kreativität da. Es sind wenig verschiedene Sachen werden gesungen. Ich saß wie gesagt nur einmal mitten im Fanblog. Da war es auch so, was die Leute anging, so ein bisschen unangenehm. Die Polen haben, als wir das Vorrundenspiel in die Polen hatten, im Sontenis 0-0 gespielt und auf einmal fingen die Polen auf Deutsch an zu singen, Auf Wiedersehen Deutschland. Also man hörte es wirklich in diesem großen Stadion auf der anderen Seite, Deutschland auf Wiedersehen, Deutschland auf Wiedersehen in deutscher Sprache. Da haben sich doch schon einige Leute arg daneben benommen auf der deutschen Seite. Also das war sehr, sehr unangenehm, die ganze Geschichte. Aber das dritte Vorrundspiel habe ich nicht gesehen. Und dann ab Achtelfinale hatte ich das Gefühl, wurde jetzt unabhängig von den Deutschen auf alle Mannschaften bezogen, dass das Fan-Klientel einfach viel, viel sympathischer. Ich weiß nicht, woran es liegt, dass man das vielleicht dann einfach nicht so gut planen konnte oder so. Aber sowohl in der Stadt als auch in den Stadien, die Leute wurden im Schnitt netter, sympathischer. Es wurde mehr gelächelt und nicht für viel böse geguckt. Es wurde weniger rumgebrüllt. Es wurde sich weniger daneben benommen. Das war so eine allgemeine Beobachtung, die ich hatte, quasi ab Achtelfinale. Das deckt sich ja letzten Endes dann auch mit den Ausschreitungen, die es dann quasi gar nicht mehr gab. Das sind ein, zwei Pyro-Geschichten, die gezündet wurden. Aber insgesamt so die Vorrunde, die vier Spiele, die ich gesehen habe, die zwei Deutschlandspiele, das waren nicht immer ganz nett und nicht ganz entspannt. Da waren halt auch echt ein paar komische Leute mit dabei. Aber Irland-Schweden hat es natürlich rausgerissen. Und Rumänien-Schweiz war auch soweit ganz nett.
Ich wollte es gerade sagen. Irland-Schweden. Absolutes Highlight, was die Stimmung angeht. Ich war zufällig im Stadion und ich hatte das Glück, mit einer, ja, man könnte fast sagen Party-Metro zu fahren, genau zwischen einer irischen Sangesgruppe und einer schwedischen Sangesgruppe, die sich gegenseitig hochgesungen haben, schon auf der Metrostation. Es hat irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Gründen länger gedauert, als deine Bahn kam und die haben sich da schon auf dem Bahnsteig warmgesungen mit ihren klassischen Liedern und die haben dann auch gegeneinander und übereinander und miteinander gesungen. Und ich habe manchmal gedacht, das wäre vielleicht mit anderen Fans von anderen Nationen anders ausgegangen. Also die Iren haben immer eher Stand-Up for the Boys in Green gesungen, was man ja auch gehört hat am Fernseher. Und dann haben die Schweden zum Teil, ich sage mal jetzt, diplomatisch und freundlich ausgedrückt, mit Augenzwinkern zurückgesungen, Go Home to Your Ugly Wives. Das hätte auch anders ausgehen können. Die Iren haben einfach gesungen und haben einfach mitgemacht und haben Party draus gemacht und haben gesagt, okay, dann singt das halt und jetzt machen wir hier Spaß mit euch und stoßen gleich zusammen an und haben einfach ein geiles Spiel. Das hätte bei anderen – das ist eine Unterstellung von mir – aber das hätte auch bei anderen Fangruppen durchaus anders ausgehen können.
Ganz auf jeden Fall. Also dieses Irland-Schwedenspiel war ein Musterbeispiel von Harmonie und Kuschelkurs. Wir waren nur vorm Stadion, da wir mit dem Taxi zu dem Spiel gefahren, haben dann vorm Stadion noch eine Stunde oder so gestanden und es war einfach alles gemischt. Also es waren die grünen Iren und die blau-gelben Schweden. Es war nur gemischt. Die Polizei hat sich nirgends eingemischt. Es haben alle Bier miteinander getrunken. Es waren alle chillig. Es haben alle miteinander geredet. Dazwischen, wie immer, viele deutsche Fans. Auch die verdammt gut integriert, sag ich mal, in diese ganze Geschichte mit rein. Es war wirklich ein absolutes Highlight. Es war, glaube ich, noch der erste Spieltag gegen Schweden und war sehr, sehr positiv, gerade im Vergleich zu diesen anderen Geschichten, die dann da in Marseille passiert sind, England gegen Russland und so. Es war wirklich ein Highlight der ganzen Reise, diese beiden Länder zu sehen.
Und vor allen Dingen im Stadion auch die neutralen Blöcke, die gab es ja gar nicht in der Form, weil ja dann gemischt die Trikots da waren. Das Stadion war ja eigentlich komplett gelb oder grün. Es gab ja gar nicht diese bunten blau, weiß, schwarz irgendwie angezogenen Leute, sondern das war entweder grün oder gelb oder gemischt. Das war Wahnsinn, das zu sehen.
Selbst unser neutraler Block, der so ein bisschen – wir saßen mal in Schweden in der Ecke, das war offensichtlich irgendwie so ein improvisierter Block. Da war so eine klapprige Tribüne, da saßen vielleicht 100 Leute drauf. Wir drei aus Deutschland, dazu noch fünf im Deutschland-Trikot und der Rest war halt Hälfte, Hälfte Schweden und Irland. Die haben sich beide nichts geschenkt auf den Tribünen, was die Stimmung anging, haben richtig schön – ging auch 1-1 aus – haben beide richtig schön sich in den richtigen Momenten gefreut. Auch nicht gefiffen, wenn die einen Feiert haben, das waren so Sachen, die in anderen Spielen aufgefallen sind, dass man pfeift als Reaktion auf das Gesinge der gegnerischen Mannschaft total unnötig, anstatt dass man selber was singt. Aber das war bei dem Spiel auch überhaupt nicht der Fall. Es war ein großartiger Ausflug Irland gegen Schweden. Wird auf jeden Fall lange in meiner Erinnerung bleiben.
Auf jeden Fall. Absolut. Auch ein absoluter Stimmungshilheit dieses Spiel und Musterbeispiel für das, wie es sein kann. Sportlich war das Spiel jetzt kein großer Knaller, aber das Drumherum war absolut Weltklasse.
Wen ich noch positiv gerne erwähnen möchte in der ganzen Geschichte sind die Portugiesen. Okay, sie haben es natürlich relativ leicht gehabt, weil es dann irgendwann lief wie geschnitten Brot.
Moment mal, die haben nur einmal nach 90 Minuten gewonnen.
Ich habe sie ja erst gesehen ab Viertelfinale. Ich habe das Viertelfinale der Portugiesen in Polen gesehen, ich habe das Halbfinale gegen Wales gesehen und ich habe das Finale gegen Frankreich gesehen und sie waren bei allen drei Spielen, ich sage mal natürlich, die Mannschaft mit den wenigereren Fans, mit dem kleineren Fan-Block, sowohl die Polen als auch die Waliser als auch die Franzosen hatten deutlich mehrere Fans natürlich dabei. Aber sie haben immer, auch wenn sie nicht geführt haben, haben sie sehr gute Stimmung verbreitet, waren laut, waren gut organisiert. Man konnte das sehen, die hatten da vorne so ein, zwei Karpos, Vorturner, was auch immer stehen, die für die Koordination gesorgt haben, hatten immer ihre große Blockfahne mit dabei und haben wirklich dreimal mich beeindruckt und es hat dreimal Spaß gemacht, in der Nähe der Portugiesen zu sitzen und den Fans zuzugucken, beim Stimmung machen. Schön.
Gibt es noch eine Nation, die euch da in besonderen Erinnerungen bleibt? Matthias, hast du noch vielleicht ein Erlebnis?
Ich war bei Österreich gegen Island, habe ich ja vorhin schon mal erwähnt. Einmal überraschend, wie viele Österreicher da waren und wie das abgelaufen ist, trotz des absolut desolaten Ausscheidens der Mannschaft, die ja relativ hoch gewettet war. Gut, sie haben dann im Endeffekt, muss man ja auch sagen, fast in der Todesgruppe gespielt mit Europameister und Überraschungsteam. Aber wie Island dann gefeiert hat, das ist ja auch so ein bisschen so, um nochmal auf die UEFA zurückzukommen. Die sind ja relativ gnadenlos. Da wird der Abpfiff passiert, sagen wir mal, beim 18 Uhr Spiel, 10 vor 8. Um spätestens 5 vor 8, nachdem die Statistiken über die Videowand geflimmert sind und der Spieler des Spiels bekannt gegeben wurde, wird dann gesagt, so, Ausgang Down, da geht es da und hin. Wer zu Fan-Modern will, bitte Ausgang B7 und wer in die Stadt möchte, Ausgang C5 oder wie auch immer. Und da wird dir relativ schnell klar gemacht, okay, hier ist der Spaß vorbei und jetzt geht es nach Hause und dann wird die UEFA-Mucke angedreht, die da von der Playlist kommt und dann das Gefühl der Rausschmeißermusik so ein bisschen. Und die Isländer, die ja gerade einen historischen Erfolg hatten, die haben einfach im strömenden Regen von Saint-Denis eine halbe Stunde nach Abpfiff immer noch mit voller Stärke im Block gestanden und gesungen und die Spieler sind nochmal raus und nochmal in die Kurve und die müssen davon überhaupt nicht beeindrucken lassen und das fand ich echt stark. Man hatte viel über die Isländer geredet, aber das fand ich echt eine starke Aktion nach diesem 2 zu 1 gegen Österreich.
Man kann, wenn man Eindrücke von vor Ort haben möchte und man nicht den Luxus hatte, so wie ihr vor Ort gewesen zu sein, kann ich nur empfehlen im YouTube-Kanal der 11 Freunde gibt es Videos und die 11 Freunde haben dann auch gesagt, es war so ein bisschen die EM der Fans. Und vielleicht kann man das tatsächlich vor allem mit Blick auf das, was da noch so kommt, bestätigt sich das fast schon von alleine. Wir werden eine WM in Russland haben, wo die Anreisewege, die Kosten und das ganze Drumherum etwas komplett anderes sein wird. Dann werden wir eine EM haben, die zwischen Bilbao und Baku ausgespielt wird, in ganz verschiedenen Orten, nicht von einer Nation als Gastgeber organisiert wird. Und dann geht es ja schon nach Katar. Das schreit natürlich auch nach einem Feiern der Fan-Kultur. Wie habt ihr es denn vor Ort empfunden? Tobi, fang du mal an. Hast du auch so das Gefühl gehabt, die Fans waren vielleicht, also sportlich hat man ja gesagt, es war eher mau. Haben das die Fans vielleicht jenseits der Stadien wieder rausgerissen?
Ja, ich habe natürlich vor Ort nicht alles mitgekriegt, aber so das eine oder andere YouTube-Video hat man sich natürlich angeguckt, auch auf dem von dir eben genannten Kanal. Die Fans waren schon positiv, muss ich sagen. Wir haben die Probleme angesprochen, die es da gab, das war in Marseille nicht schön, aber danach beruhigte es sich ja dann wirklich relativ schnell bis auf ein paar Aussetzer innerhalb des Stadions. Spielerisch, wenn man das vergleichen muss, das spielerische mit dem, was auf den Tribünen passiert ist, war es wahrscheinlich tatsächlich das Turnier der Fans. Vielleicht muss man das dann letzten Endes so festhalten und dann sind wir wahrscheinlich auch bei einem Punkt, der diese 24 Mannschaften als positiv darstellen kann, weil vielleicht wäre das eine oder andere Land nicht mit dabei gewesen, was für gute Stimmung gesorgt hat. Vielleicht kann man so versuchen, es sich schön zu reden.
Turnier der Fans in positiver wie negativer Sicht könnte man vielleicht auch noch sagen. Wir hatten ja eigentlich gedacht, dass die Zeiten der Ausschreitungen von Hooligans ein bisschen in der Vergangenheit angehören oder zumindest gehofft, dass es jetzt nochmal so massiv wiederkam, hat sowohl die UEFA überrascht als auch die Sicherheitsbehörden. Also das muss man vielleicht auch noch dazu sagen, wenn man das Bild komplett machen will. Aber klar, Turnier der Fans stimmt schon und was über die kleinen Länder gesagt wird, wie Nordirland, wie Wales. Irgendwie gehört das auch zu diesem 24er-Feld dazu. Vielleicht kleine Randaneckdote zum 24er-Feld, ohne das große Fass jetzt aufmachen zu wollen. Abschlusspressekonferenz, UEFA, zwei Tage vor dem Finale. Warum ist das 24er-Feld ein Erfolg? Weil eine Mannschaft, die in der Weltrangliste ganz vorne dabei ist, wie Holland es nicht mal geschafft hat, zur Europameisterschaft zu kommen und wir so viel Qualität im europäischen Fußball haben. Also weil Holland nicht dabei war, ist das 24er-Feld ein Erfolg. Zitat UEFA.
Ich habe so lange nach diesem O-Ton gesucht, Matthias. Irgendwann war ich auf, ich glaube, ein russischer, ich glaube, es war ein russischer YouTube-Kanal, der so zum Teil diese Pressekonferenz in Ausschnitten hatte. Und ich habe ihn nicht gefunden, weil ich das so, ich hatte das auch gelesen bei dir auch auf Twitter und ich fand dieses Zitat so unfassbar.
Wenn ich es finde, dann werde ich es nochmal, werde ich es nochmal weiterverbreiten.
Ja, generell hat sich die UEFA, UEFA fand mal wieder alles super, was gelaufen ist. Vielleicht können wir das nochmal ganz kurz thematisieren, denn das finde ich schon interessant. Du hast es vollkommen richtigerweise nochmal eingeordnet mit dem Turnier der Fans. Es gab eben auch die Negativseite. Und gleichzeitig hatten wir jetzt auch einige Dinge im Stadion, da lässt sich nicht alles verhindern, haben wir darüber gesprochen, aber es stellen sich auch einige Fragen. Danke für's Zuhören!
Ertäuscht dieser Eindruck, Matthias? An zwei Stellen kann man glaube ich so eine Art immerhin sagen, da ist, an zwei Stellen war die UEFA immerhin selbstkritisch, das gilt einmal für den Modus 24 Mannschaften, da haben sie gesagt, ja, wir haben Fehler gemacht, haben sie so zugegeben, oder es ist nicht alles so perfekt rund gelaufen, es könnte besser laufen, da ging es darum, ich weiß nicht, wie sie es jetzt verbessern wollen, aber da ging es darum, dass es ja diese vielen spielfreien Tage rund ums Achtelfinale gab, die man halt einfach braucht, weil nicht klar war, welcher Gruppen dritte nun weiterkommt und wer gegen wen und dann muss man ja auch noch die Logistik vorbereiten, dass die Mannschaften Zeit haben, sich vorzubereiten und dahin zu fahren und was alles so dran hängt, das war der eine Punkt und das zweite immerhin, man hat sich flexibler gezeigt, was die Anstoßzeiten angeht, das ist, glaube ich, nur ein Tropfen auf den heißen Stein, aber sie haben sich immerhin bereit erklärt für die nächsten Ich bin sehr froh, dass ich in den nächsten Turniere bei Risikospielen auch kurzfristig die Anstoßzeiten zu verändern und Duellen wie England gegen Russland dann auf 15 Uhr und nicht auf 21 Uhr zu schieben, weil man eben da den Alkohol als den größten Feind des Friedens ausgemacht hat, was ja irgendwie auch ein bisschen fadenscheinig ist, weil man hat das Problem definitiv einfach unterschätzt, auch als UEFA. Aber immerhin ist man da mal abgerückt von dieser es war alles super und wir haben uns gar nicht zur Schulden kommen lassen Linie, das ist vielleicht nur ein kleines bisschen, aber immerhin ist man da so weit gegangen. Ansonsten war das ein absolutes Feiern der UEFA, ein absolutes Feiern des Turniers. Da wurden, es war so eine kleine Powerpoint-Präsentation zu den Reden, da wurden also nur die Superlative präsentiert. Man hat sich gefeiert für die Einnahmen, wir haben am meisten Geld verdient seit Rekord und die TV-Quoten, da wurde sich für gefeiert, bis hin zur Zahl, dass beim isländischen Spiel nur 298 Isländer nicht zugeguckt haben, wurde so von der UEFA verkündet, bis hin natürlich und das Thema gehört irgendwie fürs Bild der Europameisterschaft auch dazu, dass bei dieser Pressekonferenz der Name Platini unglaublich oft gefallen ist. Wir wissen ja, gesperrt, verbannt vom Fußball wegen seiner Korruptionsgeschäfte und schon in der Eröffnungsansprache vom amtierenden Präsidenten Via Iona, der ja ihn ja vertritt. Der hat im Prinzip eine zehnminütige Rede gehalten. Davon waren acht Minuten Danksagungen. Er hat seine Rede angefangen mit dem Satz, wer nicht dankbar ist, der also, der macht das falsch. Dankbarkeit ist ein hohes Gut. Wir müssen dankbar sein. Und eine ewig lange Litanei von Danksagungen losgelassen. Ist auch, glaube ich, okay. Aber dann kam nicht mehr viel Substantielles und dann kamen noch so Sätze wie, wir sind in Gedanken bei Michel Platini. Er kann stolz auf seine EM sein. Und dann gipfelte das ja dann auch nach dem Finale in diesem Bild auf der Videowand. Danke für alles, Michel. Also da ist die UEFA ein bisschen selbstgerecht und hat wieder die Scheuklappen auf mit den kleinen Immerhinns, die ich da ja hinzufügen wollte gerade.
Da gab es auch ein ordentliches Pfeifkonzert für nach dem Finale, für das von dir eben angesprochene Bildchen von Platini und den Danksagungen. Da war wirklich viel, viel Pfeifen im noch gut gefüllten, weiten Rund.
Ja, da bin ich sehr gespannt auf die Langzeitfolgen dieser Europameisterschaft und vielleicht muss man das dann das nächste Turnier noch mit reinnehmen. Wird jetzt immer häufiger thematisiert die Überreizung sowohl der Spieler als auch der Zuschauer. Ich denke, da kommen dann auch so Themen, wie wir vorhin schon besprochen haben, dann vielleicht auch noch mal mit rein, die zwar auch alle lokal begründet sein wollen, wegen zum Beispiel Ticket-Nachfrage usw. Aber ich bin mal gespannt, wie es sich da weiterentwickelt, wie wir vielleicht dann über die nächsten zwei Turniere sprechen werden in der Retrospektive. Da verändert sich so ein bisschen was. Jetzt haben wir schon ganz lange über die EM gesprochen. Gibt es denn noch so einzelne Erlebnisse, die euch mit begleiten werden, auch vielleicht, wenn ihr euch noch ein Jahr dran erinnert? Tobi, fang mal an.
Mein Auto.
Stimmt, das haben wir noch gar nicht angesprochen. Du bist mit dem Auto gefahren.
Ich bin mit dem Auto gefahren, ja. Insgesamt waren es dann in dieser zweiten Tour, also die erste Tour, da bin ich nur auf einem Beifahrersitz gesessen. Das hat mir dann auch gereicht. Das waren irgendwie 1600 Kilometer. Und die zweite Tour waren dann 5200 Kilometer durch Frankreich. Man zahlt ja Maut in Frankreich, aber das hat nicht nur seine Nachteile. Klar, das kostet Geld, aber es hat auch viele, viele Vorteile. Du kannst wirklich ein ganz entspanntes Auto fahren haben. Du darfst maximal 130 kmh fahren, das heißt, alles pendelt sich so bei 140 auf den Tacho ein, also so um 130 in der Realität. Und du kannst ja teilweise einfach 100 Kilometer am Stück fahren und es nicht überholt keiner und du musst keinen überholen, weil alle fahren die gleiche Geschwindigkeit und es ist total chillig und sehr angenehm und es war wirklich fast ein kleiner Kulturschock, als ich dann am Montag nach dem Finale über die, ich glaube, belgisch-deutsche Grenze Wars gefahren bin. Auf einmal konnte jeder wieder so schnell fahren, wie er möchte und du fährst halt 100, weiß ich nicht, 50 auf der linken Spur und auf einmal kommt einer von hinten angeflogen und ballert dich da aus der linken Spur. Also das waren so Sachen, die passieren hier in Frankreich einfach nicht. Da ist Autobahn nicht immer gleich, ich habe den schnellsten und den größten und wir müssen so viel hier lang kacheln, sondern das ist einfach entspanntes Autofahren und das war so insgesamt meine Eindruck eigentlich fast vom ganzen Land, trotz aller Terrorgeschichten, trotz Polizeipräsenz und so. Die Leute lassen sich wenig aus der Ruhe bringen. Es war sehr angenehm. Ich war ja auch nicht nur immer in den Spielorten. Ich habe es vorhin angesprochen in Clermont-Ferrand, noch mal am Mittelmeer, an einem Ort, wo kein Fußball war und dann noch mal auf dem Weg zum Finale. Wir waren auch in so einem kleinen Nest. Ich habe den Namen glatt vergessen. Auch da und auch in den Spielorten irgendwie, es gibt so diese Lässigkeit und diese Entspanntheit. Es war insgesamt eine sehr, sehr schöne Erfahrung und sehr, sehr viele nette und ruhige, freundliche Menschen getroffen. Auch dieses Vorurteil, wenn du kein Französisch sprichst und ich spreche tatsächlich so gut wie gar nicht Französisch, dann kommst du da auch überhaupt nicht weit. Nein, es ist das Gegenteil gewesen. Die meisten haben es wirklich versucht mit Händen und Füßen ein bisschen Englisch, ein bisschen Französisch und vielen Wiederholungen. Man konnte wirklich, ja, es war eine schöne Zeit in dem Land und es hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht, dort durch die Gegend zu reisen und ich glaube insgesamt habe ich neun verschiedene Städte gesehen. Das war es wert, war wirklich toll.
Das ist schön zu sehen, auch wenn ich es ein bisschen ironisch finde, dass ich dich nach deinem EM-Erlebnis frage und du antwortest mit der Autobahn.
Wir haben so viel über Fußball gesprochen, dann gab es natürlich ganz viele schöne Spiele. Vollkommen okay.
Und was nimmst du jetzt von dieser EM mit? Du warst ja noch ein bisschen in anderer Funktion dort unterwegs.
Das sind glaube ich eher die kleinen Geschichten, die mir dann hängen bleiben. Ich habe ganz am Anfang den portugiesischen Kollegen angesprochen, den wir gehört haben, auch João Patero. Das sind so die Geschichten, die mir hängen bleiben. Vielleicht noch eine ganz kleine Geschichte, weil wir schon auch ganz viele der Anekdoten, die mir jetzt noch so präsent sind, ja angesprochen haben, was aus den Stadien passiert ist und was so rundum für Geschichten waren. Eine Geschichte, die auch sehr interessant war, ich war mehrfach in der Nähe von Paris im Norden, in Chantilly. Das ist ein kleines, ferdeverrücktes Städtchen. Das war das Hauptquartier der Engländer. Und da war ich drei Mal insgesamt zur Pressekonferenz und zwar an den Tagen vor dem Brexit-Referendum und nach dem Brexit-Referendum, weil ich einfach Hintergrundbeiträge machen wollte, wie geht jetzt die englische Mannschaft damit um und was heißt das eigentlich jetzt. Hab da bei der Pressekonferenz natürlich mitgeschnitten, da war nicht so viel zu bekommen. Hab dann auch mich mit Kollegen unterhalten, die mir dann noch so ein paar Sachen, so ein paar Sichtweisen der englischen Seite erzählt haben, auch was die Premier League angeht. Das war sehr spannend und dann war ich noch einmal ein drittes Mal da und zwar an dem Tag nach dem Ausscheiden gegen Island, wo dann Roy Hodgson, obwohl er nicht kommen wollte, weil er ja schon zurückgetreten, dann doch noch erschienen ist. Und eine kleine journalistische Beobachtung an dieser Seite von den Kollegen, also das war alles sehr relaxed von den englischen Seiten die ganze Zeit, total entspannt. Die saßen da in gemütlicher Kleidung, also ich will auch kein diffamieren oder so, ist auch alles völlig in Ordnung. Es war sehr warm in Chantilly und die Fragen, die da gestellt wurden vor dem Viertelfinale gegen Island, waren so ein bisschen, ja, habt ihr Angst Elfmeter zu schießen? Also so, man kann sich das vorstellen. Es war alles eher friedlich, freundlich und das läuft auch ein bisschen anders ab als bei die FB-Pressekonferenzen, die jemand zum Teil auch live gucken konnte. Also da wird das Mikrofon rumgereicht bei den bei den Granten, sagen wir mal, BBC, Sky, Telegraph, Times und dann darf jeder Journalist, der da vorne in ersten Reisen jetzt erstmal so viele Fragen stellen, wie er will, dann wird es rumgereicht und dann wird irgendwann gefragt, hat noch jemand Fragen? Dann kommt vielleicht noch ein, zwei von ausländischen Kollegen und dann wird sofort gesagt, okay, keine Fragen mehr, tschüss und dann ist die Pressekonferenz nach sechs Minuten vorbei. Das war die ganze Zeit so und ich war immer bei Wayne Rooney da und einmal bei Harry Kane. Da kam auch einfach nicht viel, muss man auch mal fairerweise sagen, von den Kollegen oder von den Spielern. Dann der Tag nach dem Ausscheiden gegen Island, gleiche Setting, gleiches Konferenzzentrum, gleiche Journalisten, alle Kollegen wiedergetroffen, die man vorher da gesehen hat. Auf einmal völlig andere Stimmung, kein Poloshirt mehr, Anzug und Krawatte, keine Frage mehr nach irgendwelchen Elfmetern. Da wurden andere Fragen aufgezogen. Man hatte das Gefühl, wir sind gerade Teil eines staatstragenden Aktes. Die englische Journal hier befragt, Roy Hodgson, nach seinem Aus. Und der hat nichts weiter gesagt, als die ganze Zeit, ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich hier bin. Was soll ich hier? Ich habe ein Statement abgegeben, ich bin nicht mehr Trainer und so weiter. Das hat dann auch nicht nur sechs Minuten gedauert, sondern 25 diese Pressekonferenz. Und dann wurden auch mal andere Fragen aufgezogen, die die mir am meisten in Erinnerung ist von einem Kollegen von der BBC. Der hat gefragt, Roy Hodgson, lieber Roy, werden wir überhaupt jemals eine englische Mannschaft erleben, die erfolgreich sein kann. In diesem Stil lief die Pressekonferenz ab und das wurde dann auch bei Twitter gecovert. Schon vorher morgens, das war irgendwie um 10 oder 11 diese PK, schon morgens ging es drauf, wir erwarten, dass Hodgson kommt, es ist peinlich für die FA, der Trainer muss kommen und nur in diesem Stil wurde da getwittert und es war eine völlig andere Atmosphäre als vorher. Und das war irgendwie auch beeindruckend, das einfach mitzuerleben, wie das da abgelaufen ist, weil dann da wurden tatsächlich auch ein bisschen andere Seiten aufgezogen und es war einfach interessant zu sehen, wie er sich da verteidigt hat und was er dann so gesagt hat, auch über die Mannschaft. Und man hat versucht da über Wayne Rooney so eine Intrige in die Mannschaft reinzuspielen und sofort die Pressesprecherin eingeschritten hat gesagt, stopp, stopp, stopp, hat längst wieder dementiert und es stimmt alles gar nicht und es war also ein, diese Pressekonferenz in sich war ein wahnsinniges Schauspiel. Als unbeteiligter, genau, der einfach mitgeschnitten hat und nachher dann einen Beitrag machen konnte mit den besten O-Tönen dieser Pressekonferenz.
Ja, das kann ich mir bildlich vorstellen. Da wäre ich eigentlich auch ganz gerne dabei gewesen. Ihr zwei, vielen lieben Danke. Das ist jetzt, sind jetzt eure letzten Chancen, hier noch irgendwie irgendwas loszuwerden. Denn tatsächlich gehen wir jetzt in die 31. Stunde EM-Berichterstattung im Rasenfunk. Ich muss sagen, jetzt langsam bin ich dann auch mit diesem Turnier durch. Das, was wir hier…
Ich hätte in Spielzeit die Vorrunde fast geschafft, ne?
Ja, und es war wahrscheinlich nur, nur ungefähr gleich langweilig, höchstens. Das können die, können die Hörer beurteilen. Ich muss noch etwas tun, dass ich in der sowohl im letzten Kurzpass, als auch in der letzten Schlusskonzerenz vergessen habe. Ich muss noch ganz kurz den Sieger des Rasenfunk-EM-Tippspiels würdigen, denn immerhin hat er sich gegen 299 andere Tipper durchgesetzt. Herzlichen Glückwunsch Dieter, Unterstrich Detroit, auch zu deinem Nutzernamen. Dieter Detroit hat sich mit 74 Punkten durchgesetzt, was sehr, sehr gut ist, denn wir hatten den einzig wahren Tippmodus, richtiges Ergebnis, drei Punkte, richtige Tendenz, ein Punkt und ansonsten nichts. Ich habe noch den Fehler gemacht, die Bonuspunkte waren noch zu viel, aber lieber höher. Es ist der einzig wahre EM-Tippspielmodus oder auch Tippspielmodus generell und ich kann es beweisen, womit ich bin in unserem Tippspiel neunter geworden mit 64 Punkten und habe fünf meiner sechs anderen Tippspiele gewonnen, die alle mit der Standard-Tipp-Regel waren. Da seht ihr mal, wie knallhart diese Regel ist.
Du hast fünf deiner sechs Tippspiele gewonnen? Fünf von sieben hast du gerade so einfließen lassen, einfach mal so. Das ist ja nicht dein Ernst.
Ja, aber halt im wichtigsten im Rasenfunk-Tippspiel bin ich tatsächlich nur neunter geworden. Da sieht man mal, wie knallhart tatsächlich diese Tippregel ist und deswegen mag ich sie aber auch. Das wird auch zur Bundesliga wieder so laufen und wenn es euch nicht gefällt, liebe Rasenfunk-Hörer, dann müsst ihr in ein Kindergarten-Tippspiel wechseln. Dann seid ihr hier falsch. Jetzt muss ich glaube ich noch die nennen, die acht die vor mir waren oder die sieben neben Dieter Detroit, sonst ist das ganz schön selbstreferenziell. Gratulation an den zweiten, Ferenc I, den dritten Nester, den vierten Trainer Bade, der ist uns hoffentlich allen bekannt, den fünften David NB, den ebenfalls geteilten fünften Lokalmatertor, den fünften Marcian, grüße an der Stelle, den fünften Stefan Tastiko und hinter mir auf Platz zehn dann Schubert129. Vielen Dank fürs Mitmachen, ihr habt sehr sehr gut getippt und es gab genau einen, der Portugal als Europameister vorausgesagt hat. Auch Glückwunsch dazu, nicht so schlecht. Ja und dann glaube ich sollte ich als nächstes euch danken, ihr zwei zum einen mit seinem Rasenfunk-Debüt und ich hoffe es wird nicht deine letzte Aufnahme gewesen sein, auch wenn das jetzt sehr lange und vielleicht ein bisschen anstrengend war. Vielen vielen Dank an Matthias Friebe vom Deutschlandfunk, liebe Hörer. Folgt ihm auf Twitter, es lohnt sich. Et matthias-friebe und außerdem auch der Tipp, die Angebote des Deutschlandfunk sind auch als Podcast erhältlich und gerade die Sportgespräche und die Sportpodcast, da lohnt sich das Abo. Das könntet ihr euch durchaus mal als Ergänzung zu anderen Podcasts noch geben. Matthias, vielen lieben Dank.
Hat mir großen Spaß gemacht.
Das freut mich sehr. Und zum wiederholten Male mit dabei, wie gewohnt souverän, sympathisch, nett und man merkt einfach, Tobi, dass man auch mal in sportradio.de öfter hören sollte. Der Ed Runner Tobi bei Twitter. Tobi, vielen Dank, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst. Und damit würde ich sagen, liebe Hörer, machen wir jetzt dann tatsächlich die EM zu hier im Rasenfunk. Allerdings muss ich noch einen kurzen Dank loswerden. Ihr könnt uns ja unterstützen unter rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen. Und an der Stelle möchte ich mal wieder drei Unterstützer danken. Zum einen Markus Ziegler, Jochen Hillebrandt und Christoph Gens. Vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank, dass ihr uns helft, den Rasenfunk ein bisschen auf finanzielle Beine zu stellen. Und jetzt ist die EM auch wirklich vorbei. Vielen Dank für die treuen Ohren, liebe Hörer. Und wir hören uns dann – nee, ich will eigentlich gar nicht sagen, wann wir uns hören. Keine Ahnung. Spätestens zur Bundesliga-Saison. Ich brauche jetzt auch eine kurze Sommerpause. Macht es gut, ciao! Das war das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.